İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar 20 Kasım 2024 Çarşamba günü saat 19.32 41. ders günümüz dersimize başlıyoruz kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar
vektör konteynerına giriş yaptık arkadaşlar en sık kullanılan STL konteynerı hatta şöyle bir espri de yapılıyor almost always auto vardı ya almost always vektör yani birinci tercihimiz çok özel bir durum olmadıkça başka bir konteynerı kullanma konusunda ikna edici bir neden olmadıkça kullanmamız gereken konteyner vektör diyebiliriz
daha sonra da üstünde konuşacağız
dinamik dizi veri yapısı indeksle erişim constant time'da sondan ekleme ve sondan silme işlemleri amortize constant time'da
contiguous memory gerektiriyor ve hepimizin bildiği gibi artık bir kapasite kavramı var
geçen dersimizin sonunda üye fonksiyonlara giriş yaptık
önce constructor grubuna değindik
sınıfın şöyle çok hızlı bir tekrar yapalım
konstruktörleri default konstruktör copy konstruktör move konstruktör
size t parametreli konstruktör
size t parametreli bir de value alan bu kadar tane bu değerden oluşturan konstruktör
range konstruktör bir range'teki öğelerle initialize eden ve initializer list konstruktör dedik
sınıfımızın gather fonksiyonlarından size'ı gördük ki hemen bütün siya konteynerlarında var
forward list de yok ilginç bir şekilde tekli bağlı liste olarak implement edildiği için
onu ileride konuşacağız size fonksiyonu konteynerın size type'ı türünden bir değer üretiyor ki temel
konteynerlarımız için size type size t türünün eş ismi ve konteynerda tutulan öğe sayısını döndürüyor
bu empty is empty anlamında bütün sdl konteynerlarında var kapasite kapasite değerini kapasite değerini get eden fonksiyon idi
arkadaşlar data ilk öğenin yani allocate edilmiş bellek bloğundaki ilk öğenin adresini döndürüyordu
yani bu ne demek vektörün int specializationı için data fonksiyonunun geri dönüş değeri pointer to int
bu da siya pileriyle birlikte kullanma olanağı veriyor çünkü normal si dizileri ya da kontegyus bellek bloğunda tutulan diziler için oluşturulmuş si fonksiyonlarını vektör içinde kullanabiliriz
bu özellik aslında standart kütüphanenin vektör string ve array konteynerları için geçerli ama dekü dek daha doğrusu dek diyen de var da arkadaşlar daha çok dek diye telaffuz ediyor ama dek için böyle bir garanti olmadığını söyleyebiliriz
üye fonksiyonların şöyle bir listesini verdik belirli bir sırayla göreceğiz dedik ama arkadaşlar şimdi burada en fazla hataya neden olan şu kapasite reallocation ilişkisine bir bakalım
arkadaşlar size kapasiteye eşit olduğu zaman bir insertion talebi geldiğinde insertion ne noktadan yapılırsa yapılsın yer yok kapasite artacak
vektör bunu kendisi sağlıyor yani normal koşullarda siz hiçbir şey yapmasanız dahi kapasite size eşit olduğunda büyüme gerektiği anda reallocation olacak
burada reallocation ne kadar olacak eski kapasitenin kaç katına çıkacak standart bunu belirtmiyor
implementasyona göre değişiyor tipik olarak iki katına ama benim derleyicimde bir buçuk kata çıkartıyor dedik onu bir göstermek istiyorum
günlük kodu böyle olsun bir vektör nesnesi oluşturalım arkadaşlar
ve dört tane ve ile başlasın
ve
ve kapasite
efendim
buçuk olduğu sürece
ne diyelim bir milyon
sürekli vektöre ö ekleyelim
arkadaşlar
i ve
örneğin pushback fonksiyonu ile
pushback
sıfır değerini ekliyorum
kapasite değerini
baştan bir değişkende tutuyorum
auto
cap
eşittir
i vekin kapasitesi
ekleme işlerinden
işleminden sonra
if
i vekin kapasite değeri
eğer eşit değilse
cap
arkadaşlar
see out
reallocation
occurred
size
i vekin size
kapasite
i vekin kapasitesi
kapasitesi
böyle bir
yazı yazdıralım
ondan sonra da
kart değişkeninin değerini
yeni
kapasite yapalım
ve
buraya
bir de
getkar çağrısı ekleyelim
evet
bakın derliyorum
eksik bir şey yoksa
zaten olsa arkadaşlarım
derleyici gibi anında hatayı
söylüyorlar
size 5
kapasite 6
arkadaşlar
size 7 kapasite 9
size 10 kapasite 13
size 14 kapasite 19
size 20 kapasite 28
size 29 kapasite 42
arkadaşlar dikkat ediyorsunuz değil mi
bir buçuk kat aşağı yukarı artıyor
bakın
şimdi bu
özellikle
üretimde
en fazla yapılan hatalardan biri
neden
eğer ben baştan
vektöre
bu kadar fazla
ve ekleneceğini biliyor isem
örneğin döngüsel bir yapıda
öyeleri
oradan oraya
oradan oraya taşıyorum
taşıyorum dediğime
bakmayın
o da taşıma mı olacak
kopyalama mı olacak
daha önce konuşmuştuk
bu
arkadaşlar
move
construct'ının
no except olup olmamasına bağlı
vektörde tutulan öyelerin ne olduğuna
hangi türden olduğuna bağlı olarak
burada çok ciddi bir
reallocation maliyeti
var
oysa
sınıfın
reserve isimli bir fonksiyonu var
bu string sınıfında da var değil mi
reserve fonksiyonu
kapasiteyi
adı üstünde
peşin peşin
rezerve ediyor
yani
vektörde tutulacak
öyeler sayısı
ya da minimal öyeler sayısı
baştan belliyse
ama
ekleme örneğin
döngüsel bir yapıda
yapılacaksa
böyle yazmak yerine
bu tabi
temsili bir kod
peşin peşin
ne yapmalıyız
arkadaşlar
kapasiteyi
rezerve etmeliyiz
işte bunun için
rezerv fonksiyonu var
bu arada tabi
rezerv fonksiyonu
kapasiteyi
tam istediğiniz
değere
çekmek zorunda değil
yani minimal o değere çekeceğim
mesela
ben kapasiteyi
özellikle göstermek için
beş yüz bine çekseydim
arkadaşlar
bakınız
arkada kol çalışıyor
hala o yüzden
gördünüz değil mi
size arttı
kapasite
yedi yüz elli bin
oldu
empty
oluşturup sonra
rezerv etmek ile
size'ı
belli oluşturmak
arasında fark var mı
çok büyük bir fark var
deniz
nasıl bir fark var
şimdi
siz kapasiteyi
rezerve
ettiğiniz zaman
vektörün
size'ını değiştirmiş
olmuyorsunuz
şu anda örneğin
vektörün
size'ı halen
dört
yani
şöyle bir işlem tabi ki
tanımsız davranış
örneğin
ivek köşeli parantez elli altı
an defa
diyebilir
rezerva
sadece bellek alanını rezerve
etmiş oluyorsunuz
ama
siz
vektörün
pil konstruktörünü
kullanırsanız
örneğin
şimdi
dört yüz bin tane
öğe tutuyor
yani
bir kere peşin peşin
bu bellek alanında
rezervat olduğu gibi
allocate ettiniz
minimal dört yüz bin
öğene sığacağı
ama
orada
nesneler
konstrukt edildi
mesela
elemanları
int olan
vektör için
oralara
sıfır değeri yazıldı
çünkü
value in
işaret ediliyor
ama örneğin
bu vektör
efendim
string vektörü
olsaydı
vektörün
string açılımı
bu
bu kez
dört yüz bin tane
string
nesnesi için
default
konstruktör
çağrılacaktı
burayı anladık mı
mesela
vektörün
date
açılımı olsaydı
arkadaşlar
e
benim date
sınıfımın
default
konstruktörü
bir bir bin
dokuz yüz tarihi
duydu
onu
bir bir bin
dokuz yüz
değerine
getirmenin de
işlemsel bir
maliyeti var
değil mi
dolayısıyla
e
fil konstruktörü
kullanmakla
rezerve edip
ondan sonra
eklemek
aynı şey
olmak zorunda değil
yani birbirinin
farklı avantajları
ya da dezavantajları
olabilir
ama yanlış anlaşılmasın
farklı avantajları
ve dezavantajları
olabilir diyorum
orada zaten
eğer o değerde
öğeler tutacaksanız
geçen dersimizdeki örneği
hatırlayın
mesela date başlık
dosyasını
dahil edelim
benim buradaki
değerlerimin
zaten bir bir bin dokuz
olması
gerekiyorsa
ondan sonra
belki bazı
koşullarda
bazı öğeleri
değiştireceksem
bu daha iyi
bir seçim
olabilir
evet
şimdi devam edelim
arkadaşlar
vektör sınıfını
incelerken
daha önce de söylediğim gibi
bazı fonksiyonlar
bazı nested type'lar
zaten
bütün
sequence container'larda
var
ama
bazı
fonksiyonlarda
bütün
stl
container'larında var
onları da görmüş oluyoruz
diğerleri kadar
zaman
harcamayacağız
şimdi
elemanlara
erişme gelmiştik
tam orayı
tekrar edelim
elemanlara erişmek
için
sınıfın
front fonksiyonu
ilk öğe'ye erişmek
için
sınıfın
back fonksiyonu
son öğe'ye erişmek
için
bütün sequence
container'larda var
elimizde bir iteratör
varsa
o iteratörü
bir referans ederek
o iteratör
konumundaki
nesneye erişebiliriz
ve sınıfın
arkadaşlar
köşeli parantez
operatör fonksiyonu
benim
Türkçe kullandığım
terimle
subscript operatör
fonksiyonu
ve
add
isimli
üye fonksiyonu
verilen
indeksteki
öğe'ye
erişimi
sağlıyor
eğer
container boşsa
front
ve back'i çağırmak
tanımsız
davranış
köşeli
parantez operatör
fonksiyonuna
geçersiz
bir indeks
vermek
argüman olarak
tanımsız
davranış
ama
add
exception
throw ediyor
burada kalmıştık zaten
ne dedik
to the exception'dan
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilen
logic error
sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilen
out of range
sınıfı
türünden
exception
throw ediyor
yalnız
bu fonksiyonlarla
ilgili
çok önemli
bir başka noktayı
da hatırlatayım
vektör sınıfıyla
ilgili değil
genel olarak
C++'la
function overloading
ile ilgili
bu fonksiyonlar
const overload edilmiş
yani
kafanızda şöyle
canlandırmalısınız
mesela
class vector
sanki ben
sınıf şablonu
değilmiş gibi
göstereyim
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
bu
operatör
köşeli
parantez
parametresi
size t
geri dönüş değeri
örneğin bu
string vektörü ise
st
string ref
ama
bir köşeli parantez operatör fonksiyonu daha var
bu ise
const
stüye fonksiyon
ve bunun
geri dönüş değeri de
const
substring ref
dolayısıyla
const bir vektör için
bu söylediğim
hem front için
hem back için
hem
subscript operator
function
hem de
at için
geçerli
böylece siz
örneğin
şöyle
bir vektörünüz
varsa
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
bir de şöyle
bir vektörünüz
varsa
vektörün
int açılımı
sivek
ivek köşeli parantez
atama yapabilirsiniz
ama
sivek köşeli parantez 2
atama yapamazsınız
çünkü
const
anahtar sözcüğünü yazmamışım
olduğu için
bu ifade
aslında
şu fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri
bu da
const pinesini olduğu için
onu
mutated
girişimi
sentaks hatası
olacak
bu bütün erişim fonksiyonları için
geçerli
arkadaşlar
elemanlara erişmeyi gördük
şimdi
modifying
operations
yani
mutating
operations
ya da
yani
container'da
değişikliğe neden olan
container'ın
state'ini değiştiren
fonksiyonlara
bakacağız
bunların her biri
son derece önemli
Arkadaşlar
bir kere
copy
constructor
ve
move
bir vektöre
aynı
türden
bir başka vektörü
atayabilirsiniz
yani örneğin
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
elimde bir başka vektör daha var
vektör
x
ve
şimdi ben
x eşittir
ivek
yazabilirim
ya da ivek eşittir
bir rvalue
expression
vektör
verebilirim
stod move
örneğin x
burada
copy
assignment
burada
copy
assignment
burada ise
move assignment
çağrılacak
ama
vektöre
ne atıyamazsınız
başka bir container
atıyamazsınız
örneğin şöyle olsaydı
buraya dikkat
vektörün
double açılımı
devek
soru
devek eşittir
ivek
yazabilir miyim
hayır
yani
tuttukları öğeler
birbirine assignable
olsa dahi
farklı specialization'lar
arasında
bir dönüşüm ilişkisi yok
bu sentaks hatası olduğu gibi
farklı konteynerlar için de bu mümkün değil
örneğin
şöyle bir kod yazabilir miyim
ivek
eşittir
ilist
hayır
ya da tersi
yazılabilir mi
ilist
eşittir
ivek
hayır
ama
bunu yapabilmek için
sınıfın
arkadaşlar
assign isimli
bütün
sequence
container'larda var
fonksiyonunu
fonksiyonunun
bir overloadunu
kullanabilirsiniz
ama oraya gelmeden
operatör
atama fonksiyonunun
initializer list parametreli olanının da varlığından bahsedelim
yani bakın şimdi ivek
eşittir
burada
l-value int vektör olsaydı
copy assignment
r-value int vektör olsaydı
move assignment
ama bakın
bunun da legal olduğunu göreceksiniz
bunun legal olmasının nedeni
burada
çağrılan
operator
assignment
fonksiyonunun
arkadaşlar
initializer listin
int açılımı
parametreli
atama operatör fonksiyonu
olması
diğer
sequence
container'lar için de
bu
yani
vektördeki
öğeleri
bu şekilde de
değiştirebiliriz
fakat
daha karmaşık
atama işlemleri için
sınıfın
assign
fonksiyonlarından
birini
çağırabilirsiniz
ya
bir initializer list
verebilirsiniz
ya
bir range
verebilirsiniz
ki bence en önemlisi bu
arkadaşlar
işte
range parametreli
böylece
mesela bu
bir vektör olsaydı
elimde
bambaşka
bir
konteyner olsaydı
setin
örneğin
şarj
açılımı
myset
set başlık dosyasında
dahil edeyim
efendim işte
burada
tutulan
değerler olsaydı
arkadaşlar
a
b
ç
gibi
izleyin
bakın
ivek'in
assign'ı
bunlar
farklı
konteynerlar
ama
karşılıklı
öveler
birbirine assignable
atanabilir
olduğu sürece
template olduğu için
bir sorun çıkmayacak
myset
begin
end
özellikle
c dizilerinde tutulan
değerler için
bunu
sıklıkla
yapmak isteyebiliriz
yani
böyle bir dizi olsaydı
int
ar
ve vektöre
buradaki
öveleri
atamak isteseydik
yine
ivek'in
assign'ı
Arkadaşlar
bu arada
atama operatör fonksiyonları
bakın
eğer atama operatör fonksiyonu olsaydı
vektör nesnesine yine
referans döndürecekti
ama dikkat ederseniz
assign fonksiyonları
bunlar
void fonksiyonu
belirli bir noktada
gördüğümüz bütün fonksiyonların
çünkü bazıları çok önemli
geri dönüş değerleri
üstünde de
konuşacağız
ivek'in assign'ı
ve
diğer
assign fonksiyonu da
ben buna
fill assign diyorum
n tane
belirli değerdeki
ö
mesela
şu anda
vektördeki
ö'yü
on tane
ö'yeler
size
on olacak
ve hepsinin değeri
doksan dokuz olacak
o zaman
atama operatör fonksiyonu ile
ismi assign olan fonksiyonun
üç farklı
overloadu ile
bir vektörü
başka bir
konteynerdeki
değeri
ya da başka
bir vektördeki
değerleri
ya da bir
initializer liste ki
değerleri
atayabilir vektördeki
ö'yeleri
değiştirebilirsiniz
bunun dışında
önemli bir başka fonksiyon
resize
sigmos
konteynerlarda olan fonksiyon
adı üstünde
size
değiştiriyor
arkadaşlar
yani
konteynerın
size
değiştiriyor
fakat ilginç bir şekilde
resize fonksiyonu
konteynerdeki ö'yeler sayısını
arttıracak şekilde
çağrılabilir
yani bir
insertion fonksiyonu
gibi çağrılabilir
ya da
konteynerdeki ö'yeler sayısını
azaltacak şekilde
çağrılabilir
bunu hemen bir örnek üstünde
gösterelim
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
üç
altı
sekiz
iki
dört
dokuz
izleyiniz
utility dosyamızı da
biraz yazma kolaylığı sağlasın diye
include ettim
önce
size'ını yazdırayım
see out
arkadaşlar
ivek
size
eşittir
ivek
size
süper
şimdi
ivek
resize
buraya dikkat
örneğin
ne olsun
on sekiz
resize'ı
on sekizi
çektikten sonra
size'ı tekrar yazdırıyorum
önce size'ın gerçekten
on sekiz olduğuna
bir bakınız
gördüğünüz gibi on sekiz
fakat vektördeki ö'yeleri de yazdırıyorum
ö'yeleri de yazdırıyorum
c-print
ivek
arkadaşlar
resize'ın
bu overload'u
sondan eklenecek ö'yelerin
defolt konstruktörüne oluşturulmasını
primitif ö'yeler için sıfır değeri
sıfır değeri
value initialize
edilecekler
sağlıyor
yani size
on sekize
çektiğim zaman
geriye kalan
on iki tane ö'ye sondan
eklenecek
ve sıfır değeriyle
tabi bu date olsaydı
default
konstruktör edildiği için
bir bir bin dokuz yüz tarihine sahip
date ö'yelerine
eklenmiş olacaktı
string olsaydı
default konstrukt edilmiş string
arkadaşlar
boş yazı olduğu için
o zaman da
uzunluğu sıfır olan
yazılar eklenmiş olacaktı
görüyorsunuz değil mi
ama
ikinci overload
o da
bizden neyi istiyor
eklenen ö'yelerin
alacağı değeri
yani örneğin
beş deseydim
eklenen
on iki tane ö'ye
beş değerinde olacaktı
resize'ı
silme amaçlı da kullanabilirim
örneğin
İVEC'in
resize'ı
efendim
dört dersem
baştaki dört ö'ye kalmak üzere
diğer ö'yeler
silinecekti
böylece
vektörde tutulan
ö'yeler
üç altı sekiz
iki değerlerinde olacaktı
olan neco
resize fonksiyonunu çağırarak
vektördeki tüm ö'yeleri de silmem mümkün değil mi
kesinlikle
resize'a
sıfır değerini geçerseniz
vektördeki tüm ö'yeleri
silmiş olursunuz
yani vektörü
clear etmiş olursunuz
anlaşıldı mı
evet
buraya bir kopyalayalım
bunun dışında
size of değeri ne olur hocam
sıfır olmaz değil mi
vektörün kendi size of değeri mi
yani bu önemli bir soru
ama bir yanlış anlama olmalı Alhan
bakınız vektörün kendi size of değeriyle
vektörde tutulan
ö'ye sayısı arasında bir ilişki yok
yani
örneğin
Alihan
ben şöyle bir vektör oluştursam
vektörün
int açılımı
bir vek
bir milyon tane ö'ye
şu anda vektörün size of değeri değişiyor mu?
hayır
zaten size of
bir compile time sabiti
runtime ile ilgisi yok
ha
eğer
bana şunu soruyorsanız
peki ne
çok
bir vektörün size of değeri nedir?
arkadaşlar
bu tamamen implementasyona bağlı
bazı derleyicilerin kullandığı implementasyonda
vektör sadece
üç tane pointer tutuyor
ya da bir pointer iki tam sayı tutuyor
mesela
lütfen dikkat
vektörün
int açılımı türünün size of değerine
bakayım
yani ben buna on iki diyemem
ya da on altı diyemem
bir kere pointer size of'unun kaç olduğuna bağlı
bir de implementasyona bağlı
yani
herhangi bir derleyici de mesela
üç tane pointer dışında
ilave bir eleman daha tutuyorsa
standart ona
niye böyle implement ettin demez
ama şimdi vurgulamak istediğim
Alihan vektörde tutulan öğe sayısıyla
vektörün
vektör nesnesinin kendi storage ihtiyacı arasında bir ilişki yok
çünkü vektörde tutulan öğeler
aslında dinamik olarak
allocate edilen
bellek bloğunda tutuluyor
anlaşıldı mı?
yani vektör nesnesinin içinde değil
şöyle bir soru da sorulabilir
Alihan'ın sorusuna ilave olarak
Necati
string sınıfında
small string optimization
yapılıyordu
burada da böyle bir
small buffer optimization
gibi bir optimization
kullanılabiliyor mu?
cevap hayır
vektörde hiçbir implementasyonun
arkadaşlar böyle bir uygulaması
yok
yani bir tane bile öğe tutsanız
dinamik bir bellek alanı
allocate edilmek zorunda
oysa string sınıfında böyle değil
değil mi?
sınıfında
standart neye izin veriyor?
küçük yazıları için
doğrudan
string nesnesinin içinde
bir buffer'ın tutulması
yazının uzunluğu
belirli bir değere gelene kadar
fiilen dinamik bir bellek alanı
allocate edilmemesine
olanak sağlıyordu
evet şimdi
diğer mutating operation'lara bakalım
ve
ilk
alt başlığımız
ekleme işlemleri
olsun
ekleme
Türkçe
ana dili Türkçe olmayan arkadaşlar
için
insertion
anlamında
ya da fiil olarak
insert
anlamındaki
Türkçe
eylem
arkadaşlar
vektörün
temel avantajı
sondan ekleme işlemlerinin
constant time'da olması
işte
vektöre
sondan ekleme
yapmak için
bizim
ilk
fonksiyonumuz
tahmin ediyorsunuz
pushback fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
ve pushback fonksiyonu
move over load edilmiş
yani bunu defalarca konuştuk tekrar
söylememe gerek var mı
yani iki tane pushback over load'u var
birinin parametresi
homes tr
diğerinin parametresi
arkadaşlar
trf ref
l-value'ları 1'e alıyor
copy constructor ile oluşturuyor
r-value'ları 1'e alıyor
arkadaşlar move constructor ile oluşturuyor
şimdi
bunu
belki daha önce birkaç kere konuştuk ama
bir kez daha göstermek istiyorum
çünkü burayı anlamak
hem kritik hem de mülakatlarda
en çok sorulan sorular
bakın şimdi
public
my class
default
default constructor olsun
ona
bir yazı yazdırmayalım
my class
const my class
ref
bu da
copy constructor
ve
bu da
move constructor
şimdi bakın
vektörün
my class açılımı
vek
reallocation olmayacağını garanti altına almak için
reserve fonksiyonunu çağırayım
çünkü
reallocation tabloyu değiştirebilir
20 tane en az
ürenin sığacağı kadar
yer var
my class
m
şimdi ekranda herhangi bir yazı çıkmaması lazım değil mi?
çünkü default constract edilecek
evet
ama şimdi bakın
vekin
pushback'i
bu bütün insert fonksiyonları için geçerli m
öyle mi?
copy constructor çağırılacak değil mi?
arkadaşlar
copy constructor'ı çağıran kim?
copy constructor'ı çağıran
pushback fonksiyonu
çünkü pushback fonksiyonu vektörde
nesneyi oluşturmak için
o vektöre koyacağı nesneyi
copy constructor'ı oluşturuyor
ama şimdi
diyelim ki
buradaki sağ taraf değeri olsaydı
rvalue olsaydı
bu durumda
diğer pushback çağırılacaktı
yani parametresi
my class ref ref olan
parametresi
rvalue referansı olan
pushback çağırılacaktı
ve o da
bizim öemizi
vektörde
my class'ın
move constructor'ına çağrı yaparak
oluşturacaktı
şimdi move constructor'ın çağrıldığını görüyoruz
bu bütün konteynerların
insert fonksiyonları için
pushback de bir insert fonksiyonu değil mi?
geçerli evet
o zaman devam edelim
arkadaşlar
pushback fonksiyonu
gördüğünüz gibi
son derece basit
arkadaşlar
ama
bir de
append-range isimli bir fonksiyon geldi
bu fonksiyon
c++
23 standartıyla geldi
şimdilik ona değinmeyeceğim
bunun dışında
emeral çelik
lambda ifadesi verebiliyor muyuz
constructor'a?
şimdi constructor'a
lambda ifadesi veremezsiniz
çünkü
constructor
sizden
hangi sınıfın
constructor'ından bahsediyoruz
vektör sınıfının
constructor'ından bahsediyoruz emirhan
yoksa my class sınıfının
constructor'ından bahsediyoruz
my class sınıfının
constructor'ı
eğer bu örnekten bahsediyorsanız
sadece 3 tane
constructor'ı var
move constructor
copy constructor
default constructor
yani parametreli bir
constructor yok
ama
lambda ifadesinden
kastınız şuysa
eğer
lambda ifadesi
ama
onun türü
my class değil ki
anladınız mı?
yani eğer soru şuysa
Necati ben öyle bir
constructor çalıştırayım ki
ona
argüman olarak
lambda expression vereyim
ama ancak şöyle olabilir
buraya bir lambda ifadesi
yazarsınız emirhan
fakat o lambda ifadesini
closure object olarak kullanıp
fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonunu
çağırırsınız
o fonksiyon bir
my class nesnesi döndürür
onlar
my class nesnesini
inşallah izleyebilirsiniz
şimdi
gelelim
diğer
insert fonksiyonlarına
arkadaşlar
burada şunu
önemli
tekrar hatırlatayım
sadece
sondan ekleme
constant time'da
eklemeyi
baştan
ya da ortadan
yaparsanız
bu arada dikkat
arkadaşlar
bu
veri yapılarında
in the middle
tam ortası anlamında
değil
yani baş ve son
olmayan
noktalar için
middle
terimi kullanıyor
anlaşıldı
değil mi?
yani ortadan yaparken
belki biz
Türkçe konuştuğumuz için
hani tam ortası gibi
bir algı elde
edebiliyoruz ama
burada veri yapısı
terimi olarak
data structure
düşünürsek
orta demek
baş olmayan son
olmayan herhangi bir
nokta demek
bunlar
linear
kompleksti
yani işinize gelmiyorsa
çağırmayacaksınız
şimdi eklemeyi
herhangi bir noktadan
yapmak için
a
sınıfın
insert
fonksiyonu var
b
emplace
fonksiyonları var
emplace'e ayrıca
değineceğiz
arkadaşlar
sınıfın
bu bütün
konteynerlar için
böyle olduğunu söyleyebilirim
özellikle
sequence
konteynerlar için
konteynerların
insert fonksiyonları
hep şöyle
burayı anlamamız
çok önemli
bakınız
bir kere anlatacağım
bütün
diğer
konteynerlarda da
buna atılmayacaksınız
bir konteyner
nesnesi olsun
insert de
o
konteyner
nesnesinin
insert
fonksiyonlarından
biri olsun
çünkü
birden fazla
overload'u var
var
insert fonksiyonlarının
hepsinin özelliği şu
bir kere
ilk parametre
her zaman
insert edilecek
konu
yani
iteratör
yani örneğin
konteynerın
begini derseniz
insert işlemi
bu konuma yapılacak
yani başa yapılacak
demek
konteynerın
insert'ü
doğrudan bir
iteratör verirseniz
bu iteratör konumuna
yapılacak demek
şimdi
burada
kişiler
ilk defa
C++'da
ya da
benzer baz dillerde
her dildeki
konvensyon böyle
değil
insertion
işlemleriyle
karşılaştıklarında
şöyle bir
beklentileri
olabiliyor
lütfen dikkat
şimdi bunlar
konteynerdaki öğeler
vektör olabilir
deki olabilir
list olabilir
lütfen dikkat
bu da
insert edeceğim
öğe
arkadaşlar
ve ben
insertion konumu olarak
bu konumu
veriyorum
hadi
bunun rengini de
yine
biraz değiştirelim
şöyle
değiştiremeyelim
evet
fill
tamam değiştirdim
arkadaşlar
bu konuma
insert etmek demek
burayı dikkatli
izleyelim
konteynerı
insert işleminden
sonra
bu hale mi
getirmek demek
yoksa
bu hale mi
getirmek demek
cevap
tabii ki ikincisi
bravo
yani bazen
sanki
buraya insert
ettiğince
ekleme işleminin
tam tersi
böyle yapılması
gerektiğini düşünenler oluyor
daha önce böyle
bir algı elde etmiş oluyorlar
hayır böyle değil
bu konuma
insert etmek
demek
konteynerı
bu hale getirmek
demek
dolayısıyla
örneğin
insert ettiğiniz
öğenin
konteynerdaki
ilk öğe olmasını
istiyorsanız
tabii ki
insert fonksiyonuna
konum olarak
ilk öğenin
konumunu vereceksiniz
konumunu verirseniz
eklediğiniz
öğe
buraya gelmiş olacak
peki
diyelim ki
pushback
fonksiyonu
yerine
insert
fonksiyonuyla
sona
ekleme yapayım
o zaman
en son öğenin
konumunu mu
insörte
vermem gerekir
yoksa
end konumunu mu
cevap vermeye çalışın
cevap tabii ki
end konumunu
bravo
tamam
o zaman buraya
geri dönelim
arkadaşlar
insert fonksiyonu
overloadlarının
diğer
argümanları
sizden
insert edilecek
öğeye ilişkin
arkadaşlar
verileri
istiyor
mesela bu
ne olabilir
birazdan
overloadları
göreceğiz
konteynerda
tutulacak
öğe
kendisi olabilir
yani
string
insert ediyorsanız
ya da string'e dönüştürülecek
bir değer
lvalue
ya da rvalue
n tane
şu öğeden
olabilir
bir
range
olabilir
hatta bir
initializer list
olabilir
yani
insert'ün de
overloadları var
ama overloadlarında
değişen
konum
değil
insert edilecek
nesne
ya da nesnelerin
ne olduğu
ama
ilginç bir özellik
daha var
ve bu özellik çok önemli
insert fonksiyonları
void fonksiyonlar değiller
geri dönüş değerleri var
ve geri dönüş değerleri
son derece önemli
insert fonksiyonlarının geri dönüş değeri
arkadaşlar
eğer bir tane nesne insert ediliyorsa
insert edilmiş öğenin konumu
şeklimize yine geri dönelim
arkadaşlar ve
diyelim ki
yine
ben
şu konuma
arkadaşlar
şunu insert edeceğim
takip edebiliyor muyuz
insert işlemi yapıldıktan sonra
bu hale gelecek ya
insert'ün geri dönüş değeri de
insert işleminden sonra
insert edilmiş öğenin konumu olacak
Oğuzhan anlaşıldı mı
Çağrı anlaşıldı mı
Alihan anlaşıldı mı
bu
tahmin ettiğimizden
daha önemli
nedenini
ilerleyen dakikalarda
göreceğiz
eğer
bir tane
değil de
seçtiğiniz
overloadun
ne olduğuna bağlı olarak
birden fazla öğe
insert edilmişse
mesela
o
sarı mı turuncu mu
bende renk körlüğü var
onun olduğu yere
üç tane öğe
insert edilmiş olsaydı
arkadaşlar
takip edebiliyor muyuz
insert edilmiş
öğe sayısı birden fazla olsaydı
arkadaşlar
yine
geri dönüş değeri ne olacaktı
tahmin edin
insert edilmiş
birazdan göstereceğim
evet
en son öğenin konumu olacak diyorsunuz
peki
şimdi
hemen
insert fonksiyonlarına geçelim
ben de sorunun cevabını
birazdan vereceğim
arkadaşlar
bakınız
çok basit bir örnek üstünde
ilerleyelim
vektörün
string açılımı
svec
bir sefer
test
kütübhanemi
kullanacağım
random field
svec
beş tane
ve
random name
c print
svec
şimdi
basit örneklerle başlayalım
svec
insert
arkadaşlar
svec
begin
orada olmayan
isim olduğundan emin olduğum için
bir de büyük harfle yazayım
Kave
ismini
ekleyeyim
ve
geri dönüş değerini
bir
iteratörde
tutayım
şu anda ihtiyacım olmasa da
arkadaşlar
sonra
a
tekrar
c print fonksiyonunu çağırarak
yazdırayım
ve
iteratör konumundaki
öğeyi de
iteratörü
bir referans ederek
yazdırayım
ve
runtime'a
bakalım
benim söylediğimin
doğru olduğunu
görelim
olsam
sorunuza biraz daha cevap vereyim mi?
ama kesin cevap vereceğim
benim söylediğimi doğru oluyor değil mi?
şimdi ben
svec
begin
yerine
svec
begin
artı 1
konumunu verseydim
bir
indeksine
eklemeyi
yapacaktı
bakın
ata petek
nazmelisa
tekin
ama ekleme
peteğin konumuna
yapıldı
ama geri dönüş değeri
yine
eklenen
öğenin
konumu
şimdi
insert'ı biraz değiştirelim
insert çağrısını
arkadaşlar
yine
svec begin
ve
buradan
başka bir overload
seçelim
arkadaşlar
mesela
initializer list
svec begin
büyük harf olsun ki
onur
ahmet
selami
bu da başka bir overload
değil mi?
arkadaşlar
ve
yine geri dönüş değerini
bir
iteratörde tuttum
önce
sorunuzun cevabını da
vermiş oldum
ilk öğenin konumu
yani
birden fazla
ekleme yapılıyorsa
son öğenin değil
eklenen
ilk öğenin
konumu
anlaşıldı mı?
evet
yani tahmininizin
yanlış olduğunu söylemek
istedim
peki
o zaman
diğer overloadlar
neler?
container'ların
insert fonksiyonları
hep böyle bakın
ya initializer list
ya fill
ya
arkadaşlar
öğenin kendisi
ya da range
hepsi böyle
mesela
hadi bir örnek daha
yapalım
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
iki
dört
altı
sekiz
ve
elimde bir de
c liste olsun
int a
a
ibeg
insert
arkadaşlar
ibeg
begin
and a
ibeg
begine
and a
ibeg
c print
and a
ibeg
Ne yapmış oldum?
Dizideki öğeleri vektörün başına ekledim.
Gördük mü?
Eğer başına değil de örneğin sonuna eklemek isteseydim,
ibekbegin değil, ibekent yazmalıydım.
Eğer arkadaşlar sonuna değil de herhangi bir konuma eklemek isteseydim, örneğin
ibekbegin artı 2, 6'nın bulunduğu yere ekleme yapacak.
Yani 2, 4, 1, 3, 5, 7, 9, 6 olacak.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Hocam sık sık aralara yüksek boyutlu eklemeler yapılan bir senaryoda
vektör kullanmanın forward liste göre bir dezavantajı olur mu?
Cevap muhtemelen.
Çünkü bu forward list olmasıyla ya da list olmasıyla ilgili olmaktan çok
arkadaşlar vektörün kontigüüs olmasının sağladığı bazı avantajlar nedeniyle.
Yani o not temelli veri yapıları genelde verdiğimiz konumdan ekleme constant time'da olsa dahi,
burada bu ekleme linear kompleksde olsa dahi,
belirli bir boyuta gelene kadar listeyi tipik olarak outperform ediyor.
O yüzden zaten almost always vektör diyorlar.
Yani bütün avantajları, dezavantajları üst üste koyduğunuzda
vektör kullanmak genelde
buna
arkadaşlar special locality de dahil olmak üzere
caching mekanizması ile ilgili
genelde bu vektör hep ağır basıyor.
Ama çok şüphede kaldığınız bir nokta varsa
performans kritik, verim kritik bir uygulamada
mutlaka profiling yapın.
Yani maalesef bu veri yapıları
böyle teorek bilgiyle
doğrudan bir çıkarım yapmayı
çoğunlukla mümkün kılmıyor.
Belki ben karıştırıyorum şu an
Emirhan'ın sorusu
vektörler L-value tutabilir mi?
Vektörler zaten L-value tutuyor.
Belki soruda bir yanlışlık var arkadaşlar.
Vektörde tutulan öğeler
zaten L-value.
L-value olmama ihtimali yok.
Adres ifadesi L-value oluşturuyor mu?
Hayır.
Adres X ifadesi R-value.
Şimdi orada kafa karışıklığını Emirhan
giderelim mi?
Bir yeri yanlış anlamış olabilirsiniz arkadaşlar.
Şimdi geçen dersimizi hatırlayın.
Ben bir vektöre X'in kendisine zaten koymuyorum.
Yani örneğin vektörün int açılımı i-vek
şöyle bir çağrı yapsam
i-vek'in pushback'i X
X'in bir kopyasını tutacak.
Soru
X bir L-value mu?
L-value
ifadeleri niteleyen bir terim.
Bu bir ifade mi?
Evet.
Bu L-value mu?
L-value.
Ama şimdi vektör L-value tutuyor mu demek
çok doğru bir soru değil.
Çünkü L-value
terimini kullanabilmemiz için
bir ifadeden bahsedebilmemiz gerekiyor.
Ozan soru olsa olsa şu olabilir.
Necati örneğin i-vek köşeli parantez sıfır desem.
Bu bir ifade mi?
Bu ifadenin bir value kategorisi var mı?
Evet.
Bu ifadenin value kategorisi ne?
Cevap L-value.
Ama doğrudan vektör L-value tutabilir mi sorusu
bence doğru bir soru değil.
Çünkü L-value
bir ifadeyi niteleyen terim.
Diğer sorunuza gelirse
vektör bir adres tutabilir mi?
Şimdi orada da bir yanlış anlama olmasın.
Vektörün adres tutması demek
vektörün
birinci template parametresinin
bir pointer türü olması demek.
Yani örneğin
böyle bir vektör olabilir mi?
Tabii ki.
Böyle vektörler kullanılıyor mu?
Eskiden çok daha fazla kullanılıyordu
ama şimdi
böyle vektörler yerine
eğer bu adresler
dinamik ömürlü nesnelerin adresleri ise
daha çok
smart pointer specialization'larını kullanıyoruz.
Soru
ben böyle bir vektöre
şöyle bir ifadeyi
pushback fonksiyonla
argüman olarak gönderebilir miyim?
P-vek
pushback
arkadaşlar yavaş yavaş bütün sorularınıza cevap vereyim.
Adres X
tabii ki
bu durumda
vektöre biz ne koymuş olabiliriz?
Vektöre
ben
int nesnenin
adresini koyuyorum.
Eğer soru şuysa
onu da geçen derste anlatmıştım.
Belki orayı kaçırmış olabilirsiniz.
Vektörün
pointer türü
specialization'ı
olabildiği gibi
vektörün
referans türü
specialization'ı
olabilir mi?
Bu hayır.
Eğer soru buysa
hayır.
Ama
bu
L value
tutabilir mi
sorusu
bu durum için yanlış.
Bu soruyu nasıl
sormamız gerekiyor?
Şöyle sormamız gerekiyor.
Hiç problem değil.
Vektörün
referans türü
specialization'ı
olabilir mi?
Yani bu ne demek?
Vektör sınıf
şablonunda
birinci template
argümanı olarak
bir referans türü
kullanabilir miyim?
Cevap
hayır.
Bunun yine
geçen dersimizde
konuşmuştuk.
Eğer bunu
yapmak istiyorsanız
bunu doğrudan
yapamazsınız.
Ama
bir arkadaşım
yazmış
geçen derste
atıfta bulunmuş
o olsam
referans
rapper
isimli
türü
kullanarak
o sınıf
türünden
template
argümanı
verebilirsiniz.
Yani şöyle
referans
rapper'ın
o da
functional başlık
dosyasında
int
açılımı.
Peki
o zaman
devam edelim.
Insertion
overload'larından
bir tane daha var.
Hadi onu da
gösterelim.
Vektörün
string
açılımı
svek
ali
nurf
eda
esvek
insert
begin
beş tane
necati
bu da fill insert
yani
bu insert işlemi
yapıldıktan sonra
jprint
svek
başta
yani insert
ettiğim konumda
beş tane
necati
olacak.
Gelelim
silme işlemlerine.
Hayır
yok
silme işlemlerine
gelmeden
çok önemli
bir nokta
daha var.
Arkadaşlar
izleyin
lütfen.
şu
basitleştirilmiş
olarak
vektör
sınıfı
olsun.
Neden
basitleştirilmiş
olarak?
Çünkü
geçen
derste
söylemiştim
aslında
ikinci bir
template
argümanı
var değil mi?
Allocator.
Arkadaşlar
bakınız
şimdi
buraya
anlamak
çok
önemli.
Soru
geçen
derste
de
sormuştum
bunu.
Template
konusunda
anlamıştım.
doğru
vektör
t ref ref
diyorum
özür dilerim.
Void
diyelim ki
bu
t ref ref
parametre
r value
referansı mı
universal
referansı mı?
Cevap
r value
referansı.
En sık yapılan
hata olduğunu
söylemiştim.
Olsam belki
kaçırmış
olabilirsiniz.
Bu
kesinlikle
universal
referans
değil.
Arkadaşlar
bakınız
eğer bu
universal
referans
olsaydı
buraya
dikkat
ben
vektörün
int açılımı
türünden
bir nesne
tanımladığımda
onun
bu
fonksiyonla
l value
r value
her şey
geçebilmeliydim
değil mi?
Ama bakın
şimdi
l value
geçtiğim anda
sentaks
hatası
olacağım.
Neden?
Çünkü bu
universal
referans
değil.
Vektörün
int açılımı
için t int
dolayısıyla
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
int ref ref.
Bu fonksiyonun
bakın
pushback'te
böyle değil mi?
Pushback böyle
işte.
Pushback
bir böyle
overloadu var
bir de böyle
bir overloadu
var
olsam.
Takip edebiliyor
muyuz?
E şimdi
bu
r value
referans mı
universal
referans mı?
Bu
kesinlikle
r value
referans.
Anlaştık mı?
Çünkü burada bir
çıkarım yok.
Ama şimdi
bakın
lütfen dikkat
şöyle bir
fonksiyon
olsaydı
template
type name
u
void
ref ref
şimdi bu
universal
referans mı
cevap
kesinlikle.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Bu
universal
referans
ama demin ki
universal
referans
değil.
Bakın
universal
referans
olduğu için
bu
ya
l value
da
r value
const
l value
da
efendim
const
olmayan
l value
da gönderebiliyorum.
Olsam
burada anlaştık mı?
Bunu
gözden
kaçırmış
olabilirsiniz.
Daha önce
bu
template
konusunda
değinmiştim.
Evet
burada bir
çıkarım var
şimdi.
Şimdi
neden bunu
anlatıyorum?
çok dikkatli
izleyelim.
Arkadaşlar
sınıfın
çok önemli
modern
C++'ı
eklenen
sadece
vektör sınıfında
değil
diğer
container
sınıflarda
da
emplace
fonksiyonları
var.
Mesela
vektörün
emplace
back
fonksiyonuna
bakalım.
Vektörün
emplace
back
fonksiyonu
şöyle
arkadaşlar
type name
arcs
ref
Şimdi aynı
soruyu
tekrar
soralım.
Bu fonksiyonun
ismi
emplace
back
olsaydı?
Soru
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi için
kullanılan
terim ne?
Parametre
paketi.
Ama
nasıl
parametre
paketi?
Universal
reference
parametre
paketi.
o zaman
bu ne
demek?
Ben
emplace
back'e
çağrı
yapan
programcı
olarak
emplace
back'e
l
value
r
const
non
istediğim
kadar
argüman
gönderebilirim.
Arkadaşlar
peki
ne yapıyor
bu?
Son
derece
basit
vektörün
oluşturduğu
yerde
bu
t türünden
nesneyi
t türünün
konstraktörüne
buradaki
argümanları
perfect
form
ederek
vektördeki
veveyi
doğrudan
t türünden
nesnenin
ilgili
konstraktörünü
çağırarak
ekliyor.
Altını çizecek
yardımcı araç ama
temsili bir
kod yazıyorum.
Arkadaşlar
temsili bir
kod yazıyorum.
Bakın
diyelim ki
buradaki
adres
arkadaşlar
vektörde
mplacepack
sonucu
oluşturulacak
nesnenin
adresi
olsun.
Ozan
takip edin.
Aslında
buranın
kodu
şöyle
henüz
görmediğimiz
bir
new
operatörü
var.
Buna
placement
new
deniyor.
Placement
new
operatörü
verilen bir
adreste
bir nesneyi
ilgili
konstraktöre
çağrı yaparak
oluşturuyor.
O zaman
adres
buysa
new
placement
argüman olarak
bu adresi
gönderiyor.
Şimdi
bu parantezin
içine de
konstraktöre
gönderilen
argümanları
yazmamız
gerekiyor.
bakın
ne yapıyor
burada
stut
forward
args
böylece
aldığı
argümanları
perfect
forwarding
mekanizmasından
faydalanarak
yani
argümanların
value
kategorisini
ve
const
nasıl
konstluğunu
koruyarak
sınıfın
konstraktörüne
çağrı yapıyor.
Böylece
ne copy
konstraktör
ne move
yalnız burada
dikkat
arkadaşlar
benim
gönderdiğim
argümanlarla
çağrılacak
konstraktör
çağrılıyor.
Burayı anladık mı?
Bu son derece
önemli.
Tabii
yanlış anlaşılmasın
ne copy
konstraktör
ne move
derken
buraya
sonuçta
gönderdiğim
yine
t türünden
bir
l value
ise
yine
copy
konstraktör
çağrılacak.
T türünden
bir
r value
ise
yine
copy
konstraktör
çağrılacak.
Arkadaşlar
genelde bakın
şunun farkını
anlamıyor
programcılar.
Bu
sanki
hiçbir şey
fark etmiyormuş
gibi.
Daha önceki
my glass
sınıfına
geri dönelim.
biraz fazla
geri döndük
ama
kusura bakmayın.
Keşke
yeniden yazsaymışım.
Yok.
Ne
kadar
evet
bakınız
bu sefer
my
class'ın
default
konstraktörünü
da
yazayım.
Yani
içine yazı
yazdırayım.
my
class
default
konstraktör.
bu
örneği özellikle
çok dikkatli
izleyin.
Şimdi
soru
bakınız
bir tane
daha
konstraktör
ekliyorum.
my
class
int
see
out
my
class
int
şimdi
vektörün
my
class
açılımı
vek
vekin
rezervü
ve sorulara cevap
vermeye çalışın.
my
class
me
vek
arkadaşlar
kuş
pek
me
ekranda
hangi yazıları
göreceğim.
Bunlar
böyle mülakatlarda
en sık
sorulan
taşıma
semantiği
vesaire
anlaşılmış
diye
sorulan
sorular.
Cevap
tabii ki
şunun
için
default
konstraktör
ve
bu
pushback
için de
copy
konstraktör.
Bravo
kaan
bravo
yazı.
Ama
şimdi
bakınız
çok dikkatli
izleyelim.
Soru
soruya
dikkat.
bunu
sildim
ve
burada
pushback'i
böyle
çağırdım.
Söyleyebilir misiniz
ekranda hangi yazıyı
göreceğimi?
Oğuzhan
diyor ki
default
konstraktör
ve
mo
konstraktör.
Kaan
Can da
aynı şeyi
söylüyor.
Bakın
şimdi
default
konstraktör
ve
mo
konstraktör.
Bravo.
Peki
soru
arkadaşlar
pushback
yerine
m
place
peki
çağırsam
ama
m
place
peki
argüman
göndermesem
ekranda
ne görürüm?
Cevap
sadece
default
konstraktör.
Bakın
sadece
default
konstraktör.
İşte
m
place
pekin
önemini
görüyor
musunuz?
ne zannediyor
arkadaşlar?
Sanki
böyle
çağırmak
yerine
pushback'i
geçici
nesneyle
çağırmak
arasında
arkadaşlar
bir fark
varmış gibi.
Peki
şöyle
çağırsam
yine
m
place
peki
çağırıyorum
ama
böyle.
Tahmin edin.
Yine
aynı şey.
dolayısıyla
m
place
peki
böyle
çağırmak
ile
argümansız
çağırmak
arasında
bir fark
yok.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Özür dilerim
bir fark
var.
Tam tersi
yok diyorum.
Yani
m
place
peki
böyle
çağırmak
ben
vektörün
sağladığı
benlek
alanında
bir nesneyi
default
konstrakt
etmek
istiyorum
demek.
Ama
şimdi
soru
m
place
peki
şöyle
çağırsam
sentaks
atası
olacak
mı?
Cevap
tabii ki
hayır.
Sadece
3 int
parametreli
Michael
A sınıfının
konstraktörü
çağırılacak.
Anlaşıldı mı
arkadaşlar?
Süper.
Evet.
Bu
bütün
m
place
fonksiyonları
için
böyle.
O zaman
vektörün
m
place
fonksiyonlarına
bakalım.
m
place
back
fonksiyonu
var.
Bir de
insert
fonksiyonlarının
m
place
karşılığı
var.
Yani
mesela
diyelim ki
vektörün
date
açılımı
d
vek
şimdi
bakın
devek
reserve
and place
back
bir
santaks
hatası
yok.
Çünkü
böyle bir
konstraktör
var.
Ama
şimdi
bakın
devek
and place
begin
devek
and place
begin
şimdi
şunu
söyleyebilir
miyim
bu
vektörde
3 tane
date
var.
İlk date
yani
sıfır
indeksindeki
bir
ama
en son
ö
yani
back
fonksiyonuyla
erişe
anlaşıldı
değil mi?
Evet.
C
print
devek
new
line
gördük
değil mi?
Aralık
Salı
arkadaşlar
bu durumda
Ocak
tatil
oluyor
değil mi?
Çarşamba
günü
tatil
perşembe
yine
işe
gidiyorsunuz.
Evet.
Peki.
Emplace
fonksiyonları
böyle.
Yani her
insert'e
karşılık
bir
emplace
var.
Eğer
insert
fonksiyonunun
ismi
insert
değil de
genel
konteynerlardan
bahsediyorum
pushback ise
onun karşılığı
emplace
back.
Vektöre
baştan
eklemek için
push front
fonksiyonu
yok.
Çünkü
isimlendirme
constant
time
operation
lara göre
yapılıyor.
Dolayısıyla
vektörde
baştan ekleme
constant
time
olmadığı
için
ama
sondan
ekleme
amortize
constant
time
olduğu
için
pushback
var
push front
yok.
Ama
ilerleyen
dakikalarda
göreceğimiz
deck
konteynerında
pushback'te
push front
da var.
List'te
pushback'te
push front
da var.
Emirhan
evet buradaki
date sınıfı
header only.
Bir arkadaşımın
bu yazdığı ödevi
buraya olduğu gibi
yapıştırdım.
Evet header only.
Tek bir başlık dosyası var.
Yani bir CPP dosyası yok.
Evet.
Şimdi geldik
o zaman
silme işlemlerine.
Erasure
Arrays
Operations
Arkadaşlar
vektörde
silme işlemlerini
yapmak için
şu fonksiyonlarımız var.
Bir
bütün
konteynerlarda
olan
Arrays
fonksiyonu
iteratör
istiyor.
Ve
bütün
konteynerlarda
olan
Arrays
fonksiyonu
tabi bütün
konteynerlarda
derken
Array'i
hep hariç
tutuyoruz.
Çünkü
Array
C dizilerini
sarmalayan bir sınıf
olduğu için
ondan zaten
silme yapmak
mümkün değil.
Range
istiyor.
Arrays
fonksiyonlarının
bir önemli
özelliği
geri dönüş
değerlerinin
olması
ve bu
iki
Arrays
fonksiyonu
en son
silinen
öğeden
sonraki
silinmemiş
ilk öğenin
konumunu
döndürüyor.
yani
tekrar şu
resme
geri dönersek
ben
tek
parametreli
Arrays
fonksiyonuna
arkadaşlar
şu konumu
verirsem
konteynerden
bunu
çıkartmış
olacak
tabi bunun için
destraklarının
çağrıldığını
da söylemeliyiz.
Böylece
konteyner
bu duruma
gelecek
ve
Arrays
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri de
silinmiş
öğeden
sonraki
öğenin
konumu
olacak.
Bu da
çok önemli.
Eğer
birden fazla
öğe
silinecekse
yani
yani şu
üç öğeyi
silmek için
ben
bir
range
vermiştim
silme
işleminden
sonra
bu
üç öğe
konteynerden
çıkmış
olacak.
Tabi ki
konteynerın
size'ı
düşmüş
olacak
ama
silinen
en son
öğeden
sonraki
öğenin
konumunu
döndürecek.
İki tane
Arrays
fonksiyonu
var.
Ama
Resize
fonksiyonuna
size'dan daha
küçük bir
değer vererek
silme
işlemi
yapabilirsiniz
ya da
Hopback
fonksiyonuna
çağrı yaparak
son öğeyi
silebilirsiniz.
Arkadaşlar
rektörde
doğrudan
değerle
silme
yok.
belirli
bir değere
sahip
ilk öğeyi
silmek
için
mesela
önce
toptan
bir anlatayım
anlamadığınız
yerde
mutlaka
tekrar etmemiz
değil ama
hepsi için
kod yazacağız
yazmalıyız
zaten.
Diyelim ki
şu
değerdeki
öğeyi
sileceğim
ama
bundan
birden fazla
olabilir.
Mesela
burada da
var
var.
Arkadaşlar
ilk öğeyi
silmek
için
find
algoritması
ile
bu öğeyi
bulacaksınız.
Find
algoritması
size
aranan
değere
ilişkin
iteratör
döndürecek.
O
iteratör
konumunu
RS
fonksiyonuna
göndererek
öğeyi
sileceksiniz.
Bunlar
mülakatların
intibik
sorusu
olduğu için
özellikle
üretimde de
çok
gerektiği
için
özellikle
vurguluyorum.
aynı
değere
sahip
öğelerin
sonuncusunu
silmek
için
tipik
olarak
aramayı
reverse
iteratörle
yapacaksınız.
Fakat
bulduğunuz
konum
eğer
bulunursa
tabii
onun
fonksiyonun
geri dönüşlerine
bakmamız
gerekiyor.
Bulduğunuz
konumu
arrays
fonksiyonuna
reverse
iteratör
argümanı
veremezsiniz.
Onun
base
fonksiyonunu
çağırıp
normal
iteratöre
dönüştüreceksiniz
ama
eksi
bir
önceki
konumu
sileceksiniz.
Değil mi?
Bunu
reverse
iteratöre
anlattığım
derste
örnek
olarak
vermiştim.
Belirli
değere
sahip
öğelerin
tamamını
silmek
için
yani
bu
açık
renkli
belirli
bir değeri
temsil
etsin.
Bunların
hepsini
silmek
için
ya
remove
arrays
idiomunu
kullanacaksınız
ama
C++
desteği
varsa
global
arrays
fonksiyonuna
konteyneri
referans
semantiğiyle
ve silinecek
değeri
geçeceksiniz.
Belirli
koşulu
sağlayan
ilk
öğeyi
silmek
için
find
if
ile konumu
bulup
arrays
ile
sileceksiniz.
belirli
koşulu
sağlayan
son öğeyi
silmek
için
find if
bu sefer
reverse
teratörle
çağıracaksınız
ve tabi ki
unarı
predikat
vereceksiniz.
Belirli
koşulu
sağlayan
tüm öğeyleri
silmek
için
yine
remove
arrays
idiomunu
kullanacaksınız.
Ya da
arkadaşlar
arrays
if
global
fonksiyonuna
vektör
nesnesinde
referans
semantiği
ile
göndereceksiniz.
Şimdi
bütün bunları
tek tek
örnekleyelim.
Arkadaşlar
mesela
sürekli
sondan
ö
silmek
vektörün
eğlenceli
olsun
string
açılımı
aspect
arkadaşlar
random
field
on
aspect
lambda
return
random
name
artı
bir karakter
boşluk
artı
random
surname
ters
yazmışım
argümanları
aspect
on
şimdi
diyelim ki
sürekli
son öğeyi
sileceğim.
Olabilecek
en basit
kod
while
aspect
boş
hale
gelmediği
sürece
öğeleri
yazdırıyorum
c
print
aspect
newline
popback
popback'in geri dönüş
değeri yok
void
get
car
csdd
lib
include
ediyorum
ekranı
siliyorum
benim
tabi
işletim
sistemimle
ilgili
ve
bakın
evet
şu anda
en son öğe
seyhan temiz
onu sildi
nagihan
yaşayavaş
onat
hamsi köylü
kardeşi
galip
hamsi köylü
kötü bir soyadı
denklemiş
kunter soyu
bozuk
kerem karakuzu
bin nur kelepçe
ediz muğulalı
halkan cansız
aytaç
sarı kafa
eğer
belirli bir konumla
silme işlemi yapmak
istersem
konumu vereceğim
örneğin burada
popback fonksiyonu
yerine
sınıfın
erase fonksiyonunu
çağırsaydım
erase fonksiyonuna
silincek öğenin
konumu olarak
ilk öğenin
konumunu
verseydim
bu durumda
döngünün her turunda
bu sefer de
vektördeki
ilk öğe
silinmiş
olacaktı
melike karakuzu
edis serinsun
yurdagül konak
yılmaz cansız
yasin yosun
güzel bir isim
bulmuş
sezai mertek
burak tilki
esin tarumar
bügen zengin
panser
kelleci
şimdi
bir de
geri dönüş değerini
önemini
vurgulayalım
arkadaşlar
yine
10 tane
öğe
bakın
diyelim ki
yine yazdıralım
jprint
sveg
arkadaşlar
name line
ya da jprint
bu sefer
doğrudan
sadece isim olsun
jprint
sveg
siliyorum şimdi
auto
iter
eşittir
sveg'in
erayzi
begini
artı
hem iter
konumundaki
nesneyi yazdırıyorum
yıldız iter
hem de
silme işleminden
sonra
yine
konteynerdaki
öğeleri yazdırıyorum
bakın
3 indeksindeki
öğeyi sildim
değil mi
şimdi
bakınız
3 indeksindeki
öğe
tanju
gördüğünüz gibi
silinmiş
sevimden sonra
artık
büşra var
ama
erase
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
tanjudan
sonra
silinmemiş
öğe olan
büşra'nın
konumu
arkadaşlar
şimdi de
silme işlemini
range ile yapalım
mesela
bakınız
sveg
erase
diyelim ki
vektördeki
ilk 3 öğeyi
silmek
isteseydim
o zaman
sveg
begin
virgül
sveg
begin
artı 3
ya da
next
fonksiyonunu
çağırabilirim
sveg
begin
artı
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
yine
en son
silinen
öğeden
sonraki
silinmemiş
ilk öğenin
konumu
olacak
bakınız
nacib
irivan
nasrullah
silindi
nefes
arkadaşlar
sadegül
beste
tansu
batıf
melek
tost
ama geri dönüş
değeri
nefesin
konumu
iteratör
renci
çok basit
bir örnek
daha yapalım
bu sefer
v sayısını
arttıralım
fakat
silince
köyeyi
dinamik
olarak
tespit
edelim
bunların da
bir tekrar
ne yapmış
oluruz
see out
hangi
isim
silinecek
string
name
see in name
find
algoritmasını
çağırıyorum
algoritmin
başlık dosyası
include
edilmeli
doğrudan
if with
initializer
kullanıyorum
if
auto
iter
eşittir
stup
find
as
begin
beg
and
name
iter
eşit
değilse
as
begin
end
see out
bulundu
ve siliniyor
as
begin
ereizi
it
er
c
print
as
beg
else
see out
silinemedi
bulunamadı
daha doğrusu
4 tane
olmasın
10 tane
olsun
daha kolay
takip edelim
okan'ı
sileceğim
birden fazla
okan da
olabilir
ilkini
siliyorum
okan
bulundu
ve siliniyor
okan
gitmiş
anıl
yalçın
bir örnek
daha
arkadaşlar
en son
yerizi
siliyorum
bulundu
ve siliniyor
silindi
eğer
öğelerin
tamamını
silmek
isteseydim
o zaman
diyelim ki
10 bin
tane
olsun
ama
yazdırmayayım
tabi
hangi
isim silinecek
remove
erase
asback
begin
end
name
asback
erase
end
ama
orda
maalesef
doğrudan
kaç tane
öye silindiğini
bilemiyorum
ya da
bunun yerine
kullandığınız
standart
destekliyorsa
daha güzeli
auto
en
eşittir
global erase
hangi isim silincek
elem
erased
hangi isim silincek
ahmet
31 tane
varmış
necati
26 tane
varmış
silindi
silme fonksiyonlarını
anladık mı
popback
arkadaşlar
eğer
deck
olsaydı
list
popfront
fonksiyonları da
olacaktı
ama
burada sadece
popback
fonksiyonu var
isimlendirmiş
diğerleri için
erase fonksiyonunu
çağırıyoruz
geriye kalan
fonksiyonlarımıza
da bakalım
ve artık
yavaş yavaş
vektör konusunu
kapatacağız
ama
tabi çok daha fazla
konumuz var
daha geriye kalan
vektörle ilgili
değil sadece
algoritmalarla da
ilgili
arkadaşlar
şimdi vektörle
ilgili
değil sadece
konteynerlarla
ilgili
çok önemli
bir kavramdan
henüz bahsetmedim
ama onu
ondan bahsetmek
için
ben size
benim de
mülakatlarda
sorduğum
fakat
gerçekten de
programcıların
%80'inin
yanlış cevap
verdiği
ama tabi
konuyu bilenler
doğru cevap veriyor
bir soru soracağım
bu soruyu
ödev olarak
verdiğimi düşünün
aslında ödevlerde
de vardır
sonra neden
bu soruyu
sorduğumu
ayrıca konuşacağız
şimdi
bir tane
vektör oluşturuyorum
siz
oradan
ilk değer
verebilirsiniz
ama ben
kendi test
fonksiyonlarımı
çağırıyorum
random field
svek
efendim
30 tane
random name
ve değerli arkadaşlar
yazdırıyorum
bunu soruya soracağım
merak etmeyin
ceb
yine aynı hata yaptım
evet
bakın şimdi
soru şu
vektörü
dolaşarak
şu işlemi yapmanız
gerekiyor
uzunluğu
5 olanlar
silinecek
uzunluğu
6 olanlar
dan
bir tane
daha
eklenecek
eğer uzunluğu
5 ya da
değilse
farklı bir işlem
yapmayacaksınız
şimdi
sorunun
anlaşılması için
bir örnek
verelim
ondan sonra
siz
dilediğiniz gibi
kodu
yazın
arkadaşlar
ama başka bir
vektöre kopyalamak
falan yok
tabii ki
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani vektörü
bir kere dolaşacaksınız
iteratörlerle
evet
düzenle
işaretle
şuraya yapıştırayım
evet
ne demişiz
tekrar bakalım
uzunluğu
5 olanlar
silinecek
6 olanlardan
evet
Cengiz Han
neden bahsettiğimi
hemen anladı
bravo
diğer arkadaşlara da
ipucu vermiş olduk
evet
uzunluğu 5 olanlar
silinecek
o zaman
bakınız
Demet silindi
arkan
uzunluğu
bit arkan
daha geldi
Beste
silindi
Süleyman'a
dokunmadım
Yusuf
Kenan
Adnan
silindi
parcan
bir tane
daha
eklendi
Jülide
bir tane
daha
eklendi
Mükerrem
kaldı
Teoman
bir tane
daha
eklendi
Yelda
gitti
Hansel
bir tane
daha
geldi
Yusuf
gitti
Necak'ı
anladık
Güler
bir tane
daha
geldi
Hüseyin
kaldı
arkadaşlar
Sevilay
kaldı
Tarkan
bir tane
daha
eklendi
ve
Dost ve
Azmi
bunlar
yine
kaldı
rektörde
evet
bunu yapmanız
isteniyor
ama tekrar
söylüyorum
kopyalama
vesaire
istemiyorum
sadece
iteratörlerle
dolaşacaksınız
yani
ister
for döngüsü
olsun
ister
while döngüsü
olsun
anlaşıldı
değil mi
sıralama
vesaire
başka
hiçbir işlem
yapılmayacak
arkadaşlar
madem
Hasan Bey
ve diğer
arkadaşlarım
Cengiz Han
söylediler
bunu
tamamen
iteratör
invalidation
dediğimiz
kavramla
ilgili
ki ben
ilerleyen
dakikalarda
yine
iteratör
ama bugün
değil
en azından
siz soruyu
çözmeye
çalıştıktan
sonra
bir dahaki
derste
açıklayayım
iteratör
invalidation
nedir
önemi
kodlamada
iteratör
invalidation
ile ilgili
yapılan
tipik
hatalar
nelerdir
onlardan
bahsedeceğim
şimdi
konuşmadığımız
fonksiyonlara
gelelim
en son gelen
range parametreli
fonksiyonlara
geçiyorum
assign'ı
gördük
at'i gördük
back'i gördük
begin'i
capacity'i
c begin'i
c end'i gördük
silme fonksiyonlarından
clear'i görmedik
hemen
clear'a bakalım
clear demek
resolve demek
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bir vektörde
mesela burada
20 tane
öğe var
değil mi
evet
see out
s
back
size
arkadaşlar
her ne kadar
silmenin
standart yolu
bütün öğeleri
silmenin
clear fonksiyonu
olsa da
s
back'in
clear'i
aslında
tüm öğeleri
silmenin
en az
10 tane
yolunu
söyleyebilirim
siz yine
clear'i çağırın
mesela neler
olabilir
clear'i çağırmak
yerine
arkadaşlar
resize'i
çağırırsınız
resize'a
0 değerini
verirsiniz
daha iyi ya da
daha kötü anlamında
söylemiyorum
önce bir görelim
evet
efendim
range parametreli
erase'i çağırırsınız
ve
range parametreli
erase'e
bul range'i verirsiniz
yani
asback
begin
end
resize diyorum
erase dedim
resize kalmış
evet
yine
bütün öğeler silinecek
arkadaşlar
başka
atama operatör
fonksiyonunu
kullanırsınız
asback eşit
vektörün
string açılımı
geçici nesne
ve bunun
size'ı 0
olduğuna göre
yeni değer olarak
bunu atarsak
bütün öğeler
silinmiş olur
bunu yazmanın
biraz daha
idiomatik yolu
atama operatörünü
sağ operanda olarak
doğrudan
arkadaşlar
küme parantezi
çiftini koymak
anlaşıldı mı
bunlar
ama
bunlardan
eğer
aksini
yapmanız için
ikna ettiği
daha birkaç tane
daha yazabiliriz
tabi ki
siz de bulabilirsiniz
bazı yolları
efendim ne yapacaksınız
clear fonksiyonunu
çağıracaksınız
devam
arkadaşlar
vektör
kapasite yeterli
olmadığı zaman
reallocation ile
kapasiteyi
büyütüyor
ama
kapasiteyi
otomatik olarak
büzmüyor
yani bazen de
kötü kodlama
örneği olarak
bu karşımıza çıkıyor
yani vektör örneğin
100 bin tane
öğeyi doldurmuş
ama ondan sonra
öğelerin
çoğunu silmiş
ama çok az
öğeyle
programın
diyelim ki
sonuna kadar
o vektörü
kullanacak
o kapasite
halen
allocate edilmiş
durumda
yani siz
vektördeki
öğeleri
sildiğiniz için
kapasiteyi
otomatik olarak
düşürmüyorsunuz
hemen bunun
bir örneğini
yapalım
çok basit bir örnekle
gösterelim
bakın vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
100 bin
şu anda
bu vektörün
kapasitesi
en az
100 bin
tam 100 bin
olmak zorunda
değil
ivek
kapasite
eşittir
ivek
kapasite
ve şimdi ben
ivek
a
resize
ya da
ivek
erase
begin
artı 5
ivek
end
hangi silme fonksiyonu
olduğu önemli değil
anlamında
öğelerin
önemli bir kısmını
sildim
arkadaşlar
size düştü ama
kapasite düşmedi
anen o kapasiteyi
tutuyor
eğer bu vektörü
bu sayesinde
kullanmaya devam
edecekseniz
muhtemelen
o
allocate
ettiğiniz
bellek bloğunu
geri vermek
isteyeceksiniz
çünkü
memory
allocate edilmek
istenmesi
durumunda
belki de artık
bu bir problem
oluşturacak
eğer bunu
yapmak
isterseniz
sınıfın
shrink to fit
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
ama
buraya dikkat
shrink to fit
modern
C++
eklendi
arkadaşlar
modern
C++
önce
kapasiteyi
size'a büzmek
için
swap
trick
denilen
bir
ideom
kullanıyordu
o zamanların
popüler
mülakat
sorusu da
buydu
swap
trick
biliniyor
mu
bilinmiyor
bakın
şimdi
swap
trick
şöyle
yapılıyordu
artık
gerek yok
bu arada
söyleyelim
shrink to fit
çağırmanız
gerekiyor
peki
hocam
bellekte
yer yok
ben başka
işlemler
yapıyorum
bellek kendiliğinden
kullanılmayan
kapasiteyi
hayır
asla
öyle bir şey
olmaz
ayağın
diyor ki
yani
derleyici
optimizasyon
yaparak
o
kullanılmayan
kapasiteyi
geri verebilir mi
veremez
çünkü
neden
kapasite otomatik
olarak
büzülmüyor
ingilizce
kullanılan
fiil işte
shrink
tekrar
çıkmayacağı
ne malum
yani
benim şimdi
bu vektördeki
V sayısını
ona düşürmem
bundan sonraki
kodlarda
tekrar bunun
öne sayısını
50 bine
100 bine
1 milyona
çıkartmayacağım
anlamına gelmiyor ki
asla öyle bir
optimizasyon
yapamaz
anlaşıldı mı
evet
bakın bakın
swap trick'e
bakın
arkadaşlar
vektörün
ring açılımı
bir geçici
nesne
oluşturuyorum
botanlar
bracing
ışın
onu
string değilmiş
intmiş
ibekle
konstruct ediyorum
ama
swap fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
arkadaşlar
yine ibekle
swap ediyorum
gördüğünüz gibi
kapasitesi
ona düştü
gördünüz değil mi
bu
idiomatik yapıya
swap trick
deniyordu
yani swap hilesi
anlamında
ama
günümüzde
buna gerek yok
yalnız bu arada
şuna da
dikkat çekmek
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
standart
shrink to fit'e de
öyle demiş
non binding
shrink request
yani siz
shrink to fit
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınız zaman
bu yapılmak
zorunda değil
isterseniz
standarta bakın
ama değerli işlerin
hemen hepsinin
implementasyonda
bu yapılıyor
gerçekten
efendim
o zaman
böyle yazmak yerine
ibekle
shrink to fit
bu işi
yapmaya
aday
evet
saat
21.15
bir ara verelim
arkadaşlar
21.35
devam edeceğiz
arkadaşlar
C++ 23
standartını
saymazsanız
geriye kalan
iki tane
fonksiyonumuz var
sadece
biri
get allocator
adı üstünde
allocator'ı
get eden
fonksiyon
yani
sınıfın
kullandığı
allocator'ı
geri dönüş
değeriyle
veren
fonksiyon
örneğin
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
auto
up
eşittir
ivek'in
get
allocator'ı
ve
cout
en azından
bir
pipe
id
operatörünü
kullanalım
pipe
id
operatörüne
a'yı
operant olarak
verelim
sınıfın
name fonksiyonunu
çağıralım
böylece
stut
allocator'ın
int specialization'ı
olduğunu
en azından
benim
derleyicimin
ürettiği
kodda
göstermiş
olalım
class
stut
allocator'ın
int açılımı
default template
argümanı
kullandığım
için
bir de
max size
fonksiyonu
var
burada
max size
konteynörün
tutabileceği
en büyük
sayı
öye sayısını
adı üstünde
max size
veriyor
bu
statik bir
üye fonksiyon
değil
statik üye fonksiyon
olmamasının
nedeni
arkadaşlar
allocator'a
bağlı olması
o yüzden
non-statik üye fonksiyon
iwek'in
max size
mesela
kaç tane
int
tutabilir
bunu
max size'ın
geri dönüş
değeriyle
elde
edebiliyorum
arkadaşlar
şimdi konuyu
biraz değiştireceğim
normalde
vektör
konteynöründen
sonra
hemen
diğer
sequence
konteynörlerine
geçebilirdim
deck
list
forward list
ve
arkadaşlar
array
fakat
algoritmalara
bir geri dönmek
istiyorum
hazır
vektörü
görmüşken
ve
grup grup
bazı
algoritmaları
hepsini
değil ama
aralarda
anlatacağım
yani
kurs
bittiğinde
algoritmaların
%100'ü
olmasa da
belki %90'ını
fiilen
görmüş
olacağız
bugün
değinmek
istediğim
algoritmalar
sıralamayla
bir şekilde
ilgili
algoritmalar
o yüzden
sıralama
algoritmaları
demiyorum
arkadaşlar
bakınız
algoritmaları
standartta
belirli
gruplara
ayırıyor
cppreference.com'da
da görebilirsiniz
benim
bahsedeceğim
algoritmalar
sıralamayla
ilgili
hangi grup
önce grup
olarak şöyle
bir göstereyim
evet
bir
partisyon
algoritmaları
bu sırayla
değil
önce hangi
algoritmaları
ele alacağız
onları bir
açıklayayım
yani
arkadaşlar
buradaki
is partitioned
partition
partition copy
stable partition
ve partition point
sonra sıralama
algoritmaları
sort
stable sort
partial sort
arkadaşlar
copy
is sorted
until
end element
algoritmaları
bunun dışında
yine
arkadaşlar
sıralamayla
doğrudan
ilgili
değil
ama
dolaylı olarak
belki ilgili
heap
algoritmaları
bunlar
bakalım
burada da
bulalım
evet
push heap
hop heap
make heap
sort heap
c++
20'ye gelen
arkadaşlar
range
algoritmalarını
saymıyorum
is heap
until
algoritmaları
şimdi bunları
belali bir sırayla
göreceğiz
arkadaşlar
sıralamayla
başlayalım
sıralama
üretimde
en fazla
kullandığımız
algoritma
gruplarından
biri
değil mi
arkadaşlar
STL'de
sort
doğrudan
sıralama
algoritması
ve
sort
algoritmasının
iki tane
overloadu
var
arkadaşlar
bu overloadlardan
biri
L'si
kullanıyor
diğeri ise
karşılaştırma
kriterini
fonksiyonun
parametresini
istiyor
yani bir de
predikat parametresi
var
ama
ben
ondan önce
araya bir konu
daha alayım
algoritmaları
daha iyi
anlayabilmemiz
için
standart
fonksiyon
nesnelerinden
de bahsedelim
önümüzdeki
derslerde
en çok
kullanacağımız
başlık
dosyalarından
biri
functional
başlık
dosyasında
hem fonksiyon
adaptörleri
dediğimiz
arkadaşlar
sınıflar
var
hem bazı
fonksiyonlar
var
adaptör olarak
görev yapan
hem de
standart
fonksiyon
nesneleri
dediğimiz
İngilizce şöylesi öğreniyor
standart
function
object
belirli
sınıflar
var
şimdi
bu standart
function
object
sınıfları
bildiğimiz
aslında
funktör
klaslar
önce genel
mantığını
bir anlamaya
çalışalım
arkadaşlar
ben şöyle
bir
sınıf
yazsam
template
park
name
t
klas
ve bu sınıfa
hatta klas
da olmasın
strak olsun
şöyle bir
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör
fonksiyonu
yazsam
operatör
artı
const
t
ref
left
lhs
const
t
ref
rhs
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değeri
t türünden
olsa
ve fonksiyonun
ve fonksiyonun kodu
da
şöyle olsa
return
lhs
artı
rhs
şimdi
önce sorularıma cevap
vermeye çalışın
o zaman ben
örneğin
bu sınıf
türünden
bir nesne
oluştursam
örneğin
plus'ın
int açılımı
türünden
bir
nesne
oluştursam
ve bu nesneyi
fonksiyon çağrı
operatörünün
operandı yapıp
örneğin
ve 5
değerlerini
arkadaşlar
bu fonksiyona
argüman olarak
göndersen
takip edebiliyor musunuz
parametre isimleri
yanlış olmuş
düzelteyim
rhs
teşekkür ederim
evet
operatör
t türünden
geri dönüş
değeri olan
operatör artı
tabi bu
member operatör
fonksiyonu
olacaksa
böyle olması
lazım
değil mi
evet
o zaman
şöyle diyelim
arkadaşlar
evet
sınıfın
operatör artı
fonksiyonu
böyle
ama bu
member operatör
fonksiyonu
global operatör
olması için
örneğin
nasıl yazabilirim
bunu
friend fonksiyonu
olarak yazabilirim
const
operatör artı
ama fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonu
yazmak istemiştim
değil mi
o zaman
tekrar düzeltelim
diyelim ki
t
operatör
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör artı
değil
const
p
rhs
şimdi oldu
const
p
rhs
tamam
arkadaşlar
dolayısıyla
şimdi
ben
bu nesneyi
fonksiyon çağrı
operatörünün
operandı
yaptığımda
bu fonksiyon çağıracak
bu fonksiyon da
operantlarının
toplamını
döndürecek
değil mi
isterseniz
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini
doğrudan
standart
output'a
yazdıralım
dikkatli takip edin
sadece
e
şimdi
hatta
bu işi
yaparken
ben
doğrudan
temporary object
de kullanabilirim
değil mi
önce çıktığı
görün
böyle yazmak
yerine
şöyle de
yazabilirim
plus
arkadaşlar
int
geçici
mesne
bu şekilde
de
yazabilirim
ama
daha da
önemlisi
böyle bir
function
objekti
arkadaşlar
örneğin
bir fonksiyona
argüman olarak da
gönderebilirim
jenerik bir fonksiyona
mesela
transform algoritmasını
düşünün
transform algoritmasının
bir range alan
overload'unu
düşünün
ben şimdi
kod yazmayacağım
şöyle olsaydı
transform
ne yapıyordu
birinci
ikinci parametreye
birinci kaynak range
alıyordu
diyelim ki
xbegin
xant
üçüncü parametreye
ikinci kaynak range'in
başlangıcını
alıyordu
ybegin
arkadaşlar
dördüncü parametreye
hedef range'in
başlangıcı
iteratörünü
alıyordu
destbegin
ve binary
decolable
istiyordu
ve bu range'deki
iki kaynak range'deki
karşılıklı
ve yi
o fonksiyona gönderip
fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerini
bu konumdan itibaren
yazıyordu
o zaman
böyle bir fonksiyona
çağrı yaparken
örneğin
az önceki
plus
türünden
bir geçici nesneyi
argüman olarak
gönderirsem
bu durumda
gönderilen fonksiyon
aslında
toplama işlemini
yapan bir fonksiyon
olacak değil mi?
işte standart kütüphanede
gerçekten
böyle
fonksiyon nesneleri var
aklınıza gelen
operatörlerin
hemen hepsi için
bir
function object type var
örneğin
en çok kullanılanlardan biri
less
az önceki kodu
biraz daha değiştirelim
eğer bu sınıfın
ismi
less olsaydı
arkadaşlar
ve buradaki kod da
şöyle olsaydı
boğul
return
lhs
küçük
rhs
ben
binary
predikat isteyen
herhangi bir
algoritmaya
less'in
alanca
specialization'ı
türünden
bir
nesne
örneğin
pr value da olabilir
geçseydim
o algoritmada
x küçüktür
y işlemini
yapıyor
olurdu
değil mi
gerçekten de
stl algoritmalarının
arkadaşlar
bir kısmı
less'i kullanıyor
equal to
dediğimiz
fungları kullanıyor
bunların hepsi
fonksiyon nesneleri
mesela
birkaç tanesini
göstereyim
gerçekten plus var
arkadaşlar
örneğin
plus'ın
int açılımı
geçici nesne
arkadaşlar
artı
functional
başlık
dosyasındaki
plus'ın
int açılımı
arkadaşlar
efendim
less var
less'in
int açılımı
altyazı
altının
çizmesine
bakmayın
bakalım
neden
çiziyor
evet
bazen takılıyor
böyle
gözlik
bildirimi de var
evet bakın
less'in
int açılımı
efendim
virgül 5
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonu
argüman olarak
gönderiyorum
o zaman
bu ne döndürecek
post döndürecek
değil mi
ya da
plus'ın
int açılımı
virgül 5
geri dönüş
değeri
olacak
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
bazen
yanlış bir şey
yazmış olabiliyorum
çok da önemli
değil
şimdi doğrusunu
yazdık
teşekkür ederim
bu arada
evet
arkadaşlar
mesela
efendim
minus
negate
gibi
bütün operatörlere
hemen bütün operatörler için
böyle nelerimiz var
fonksiyon nesnelerimiz var
mesela bir tanesi
birazdan örneğimizde
yer alacak
greater
nasıl less
a küçüktür
b işlemini
yaptırıyorsa
örneğin
greater'ın
int açılımı
buna
virgül
bunları argüman olarak
gönderirsem
10 büyüktür
işlemini yapacak
tabi derleyici bunları
tipik olarak
optimize ediyor
yani sizin böyle bir çağrı
yapmanızda
fiilen
10 büyüktür
5 yazmanız arasında
bir fark kalmıyor
arkadaşlar
functional
bunch deck
dosyasında
mesela burada
arama yapalım
bütün
function
objektlerimizi
standart
function
objektlerimizi
görelim
evet
functional
başlık dosyasında
zaten burada
gösterecek
arkadaşlar
evet
bakın şimdi
plus
x artı y
işlemini yapıyor
minus
x eksi y
işlemini yapıyor
multiply
x çarpı y
işlemini yapıyor
divide
modulus
negate
yüneri operatörler
içinde var
eksi x
işlemini yapıyor
equal to
eşit eşit
karşılaştırmasını
yapıyor
greater
less
equal
arkadaşlar
gördüğünüz gibi
logical
or logical
not
bitent
bitor
bitexor
gördüğünüz gibi
fonksiyon
operatörlerin
hemen hepsi için
bir
functional
objekt var
arkadaşlar
mesela
kullanımlarına
birkaç
örnek verelim
mesela
izleyin
en basit örnek
transform
çok basit bir
transform örneği
yapalım
vektörün
int açılımı
ibek
transform
begin
ibek
end
arkadaşlar
izleyin
negate'in
negate
sign operator
minus
oydu değil mi
negate'in
int açılımı
türünde
geçici
nesne
3.
parametreye de
yine
ibek
begin
o zaman
ne yapmış
oluyorum
bu range
teki
öğeleri
bu
polibla
argüman
olarak
göndereceğim
geri dönüş
değerinde
bu konumdan
itibaren
yazacağım
yani
range'in
kendisini de
bu yolla
değiştirebilirim
bakınız
jprint
ibek
gördünüz mü
başka bir örnek
mesela
arkadaşlar
burada
negate'in
int
açılımı
yerine
bu arada
şunu da söyleyeyim
şimdi
modern c++'dan
önce
burada
template
argümanını
yazmak
arkadaşlar
template
parametresine
karşılık gelen
template argümanını
eksplisit
olarak
yazmak
zorunluydu
ama
şimdi
burada
artık
modern c++'la
birlikte
tıkarım
yapılabiliyor
yani doğrudan
negate
türünden
geçici nesneyi
template argümanını
eksplisit olarak
belirtmeden
bu şekilde
yazabilirim
şimdi bana
diyeceksiniz ki
Necati
bu işi yapmak için
negate'i
kullanmak yerine
ben
bir
lambda
expression
kullanabilir miydim
tabii ki
mesela böyle
yazmak yerine
şöyle de
yazabilirdim
lambda
ifadesi
int x
arkadaşlar
ya da
auto x
return
eksi x
böyle yazsaydım
parametreyi yanlış
yazmışım
küme parantezi
koymuşum
evet
böyle yazsaydım
sonuçta bir değişiklik
olacak mıydı
int x
hayır
bu sefer de
colable olarak
bu kullanılacaktı
şimdi
çok tartışılan
bir konu
burada ben kesiklikle
negate'i kullanırdım
ama
efendim öyle durumlar
var ki
lambda ifadesi de
kullanabilirsiniz
standart fonksiyon
nesnesini de
kullanabilirsiniz
bunu mu kullanayım
yani bu soruya
doğrudan
şunu kullanın
diyemem
ama
çoğunlukla
standart fonksiyon
nesnesini
kullanmak
daha kolay
okunan
standart olduğu için
bir kod oluşturuyor
ama yine
genelleme yapmamakta
fayda var
arkadaşlar bakın
en tipik örneği
sort algoritması
sort
sıralama
algoritmalarına
geçmeden önce
biraz fonksiyon
nesnelerinden
bahsettim ki
şimdi
ilk sıralama
algoritmasında
bu
function
object'in
kullanımı
bizim için
iyi bir örnek
olacak
arkadaşlar
sort
random
access
terörü
istiyor
ve
less
funktörünü
kullanarak
karşılaştırma
kriteri olarak
less funktörünü
kullanarak
aldığı
range'i
sıralıyor
yani
hemen bir örnek
verelim
bakınız
vektörün
date açılımı
devek
random field
arkadaşlar
devek
begin
begin diyorum
devek
diyelim ki
20 tane
tarih
date'in
şöyle bir
fonksiyonu da
vardı
yanılmıyorsam
random
evet
şimdi
bunları
sıralamak için
sort'u çağırıyorum
sort
tabii ki
algoritm başlık
dosyasında
devek
begin
end
sort'u
iyi öğrenmemiz
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
sort
algoritması
farklı farklı
algoritmalar
kullanılabilir
ama
enlogen
karmaşıklığında
bir algoritma
benim gördüğüm
eğer bir değişiklik
olmadıysa
implementasyonların
çoğunluğu
arkadaşlar
intro
sort
algoritmasını
kullanıyor
intro
sort
hibrit bir
algoritma
quick
sort'la
merge
sort
hibriti
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
ama tabii
standart
herhangi bir şekilde
şu algoritma
kullanılacak
demiyor
fakat
less funktörünü
kullanıyor
bu overload
dolayısıyla
bizim tabirimizde
küçüpten büyüğe
doğru sıralıyor
ama küçüpten büyüğe
sıralamak ne demek
yani aslında
karşılaştırmanın
küçüptür
operatörüyle
yapılması demek
sıralamadan sonra
jprint
fonksiyonuyla
arkadaşlar
yazdırayım
ve
tabii
date'in
küçüptür
operatörünün
ne şekilde
implemente edildiğine
bağlı olarak
date'ler
küçükten büyüğe
sıralanacak
işte bizim için
küçük tarih
eski tarihmiş
14 Ekim
10 Eylül
vesaire
görüyorsunuz
tarihler
küçükten büyüğe
şimdi
eğer
sortu
reverse
teratörle
ağırsaydım
o zaman
büyükten küçüğe
sıralamış olurduk
yani
büyükten küçüğe
sıralamanın
yollarından biri
bu olabilirdi
görüyorsunuz
ama
yine
bir başka
overloadu var ki
daha önce
bahsetmiştik
bizden
karşılaştırma
kriterini
alıyor
şimdi ben
karşılaştırma
kriteri olarak
greater
funktörünü
verse
bu arada bir şeye
dikkat edelim
böyle çağırmakla
aslında böyle çağırmak
arasında bir fark yok
yani
default overload
zaten
less'i kullanıyor
ama ben
bu arada yine
reverse
teratör kalmasın
evet
ama ben
less yerine
greater
funktörünü
kullansaydım
burada
karşılaştırma
kriteri
büyüktür
operatörünü
kullanacağım
tabi arkadaşlar
bunların
çalışması için
ilk örnekte
date
nesnelerinin
küçüktür operatörüyle
karşılaştırılabiliyor
olması gerekiyor
ya da burada
büyüktür operatörüyle
karşılaştırılabiliyor
olması gerekiyor
evet
ama ben
herhangi
standart olmayan
greater
kullanmak yerine
başka bir
karşılaştırma
kriterini de
kullanabilirdim
değil mi
tabi böyle
yazmakla
bakın yine aynı
şekilde
şimdi greater
kullanmakta
avantajlı
eğer greater
standart olmasaydı
o zaman
şöyle bir lambda
ifadesi
yazacaktım
const
string
rev
s1
const
string
rev
s2
arkadaşlar
return
s1
büyük s2
ve bunu mu yazmak
daha kolay
ya da daha kolay
okunuyor
yoksa
doğrudan
greater
function
tabi siz şimdi
arkadaşlarımın
çoğu greater'ı
ilk defa gördüğünüz için
belki aynı algıyı
yaratmıyor
ama
defalarca bunu
kullanan
okuyan
yazan için
greater'ı
gözün seçmesi
ayırt etmesi
algılaması
çok daha
kolay
ama
kendi karşılaştırma
kriterimi de
verebilirdim
mesela şöyle bir
karşılaştırma kriteri
olsaydı
daha önce de yazmıştı
const
doto f
eşittir
şuradan kopya
çekeyim
return
s1
length
küçük
s2
length
string olsun
random
name
ya da
lengthleri eşit
aynı zamanda
s1
küçük
s2
evet
bu const
doto f
pardon
lambda ifadesini
yazmışım sadece
tamam herhalde
değil mi?
ve burada da
f'i kullansaydım
karşılaştırma kriteri
olarak
bu kullanılacaktı
evet bakın
kısa olanlar
başta
uzun olanlar
daha sonra
ama aynı uzunlukta
olanlar da
lexikografical
compared
ahmet cihan
derin
eylül
galip
hakkı
vesaire
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
evet
yani
iki tane aslında
overload'u var
birinci overload'u
l'si kullanıyor
ikinci overload'u
binary
predikat'ı
argüman olarak
istiyor
karşılaştırma işlemi için
sizin gönderdiğiniz
binary
predikat'ı
istiyor
greater'ı
kullanırsanız
büyük bir
karşılaştırması
yapmış
oluyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
yine isterseniz
burada
bu sefer
küçükten
büyüğe ve
büyükten
küçüğe'yi
böyle de bir
gösterelim
bakın
küçükten
büyüğe
evet
büyükten
küçüğe
greater
factor'ını
gönderdiğimde
greater
factor'ı
türünden
geçti
nesneyi
gönderdiğimde
algoritmaya
argüman olarak
gördüğünüz gibi
sıralama
büyükten
küçüğe oldu
arkadaşlar
şimdi
normalde ben
C kursunda
anlatıyorum
bir
sort algoritmasının
stable olup
olmaması
son derece
önemli
stable
sort ne
demek
aynı konu
artışın
algoritmasında
da karşımıza
çıkacak
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
ben
verileri
sıralayacağım
bunlar
person
türünden
veriler
olsun
metin
ahmet
efendim
metin
ne olsun
burcu
metin
selim
ve
bu kişilerin
aynı zamanda
yaşları da olsun
mesela bu
34 yaşındaki
metin
bu
47 yaşındaki
metin
bu
16 yaşındaki
metin
fakat
karşılaştırma
kriteri
isim
ve
lexikografical
compare
arkadaşlar
o zaman
bu veriler
sıralandığında
şu hale
gelecek
değil mi
ahmet en başta
sonra
burcu
metinler
sonra
selim
eğer
karşılaştırma
arkadaşlar
greater gibi
faktörlerle
verdiğimiz ifade
karşılaştırılması
olursa
syntax hatası
olur
çünkü
compile time'da
derleyici
bu kodu yazıyor
yani
emirhan
beyin sorduğu
şu yanlış anlamadıysam
örneğin
ben
greater
faktörünü
kullandım
ama
büyüktür
işlemi
yapılamıyor
yani
sınıfın
büyüktür
karşılaştırmasını
yapacak bir
fonksiyonu
member
funksiyonu
ya da
free
funksiyon
yok
o zaman
syntax hatası
olur
runtime ile
ilgisi
yok
anlaşıldı mı
aynı
durum
bakın
onu çok daha basit
şöyle gösterebilirim
emirhan
izleyin
class
my class
o yüzden
özellikle
custom type'lar
söz konusu olduğu zaman
buraya dikkat
iki tane
önemli fonksiyon
tipik olarak
bulunması gerekiyor
çünkü bazı
algoritmalar
örneğin
find algoritması
orada anlatmıştım
nesnelerin
değerlerinin
aynı olup
olmadığını
sınamak için
eşit eşiti
kullanıyor
ama bazı
algoritmalar
arkadaşlar
karşılaştırma
işlemini
yapmak için
küçüktür
operatörünü
kullanıyor
dolayısıyla
eğer algoritma
eşit eşiti
kullanıyorsa
o
equal to
kullanıyor
eğer algoritma
küçüktür
karşılaştırması
yapıyorsa
l'si
kullanıyor
takip edebiliyor
musunuz
bir örnek
verelim
şimdi
mesela
ben vektörde
my class
nesnelerini
tutsaydım
my class
vec
ve
100 tane
my class
nesnesi
olsaydı
değerlerin ne
olduğu
önemli değil
şimdi
sort algoritmasını
çağırsaydım
sort
vec begin
vec end
eğer sorunuzu
doğru anladıysam
bu da
onunla
neredeyse
aynı soru
ne olur
exception
mı
throw
eder
yoksa
syntax
hatası
mı
olur
cevap
syntax
hatası
olur
çünkü
derleyici
bu bir
fonksiyon
şablonu
olduğu için
fonksiyonu
compile time
da yazıyor
ve compile time
da sort
algoritmasından
bir
specialization
oluşturduğunda
orada
my
class
nesneleri
küçüktür
operatörün
operanda
olacak
ama
my class
sınıfı
türünden
nesnelerin
küçüktür
operatörüyle
karşılaştırılması
mümkün mü
cevap
hayır
o yüzden
ne olacak
syntax
hatası
olacak
anlaşıldı
mı
emir
ama
bakın
şimdi
örneğin
ben sınıfa
şöyle bir
küçüktür
operatör
fonksiyonu
koysaydım
public
bul
operatör
küçük
ve
passed
my
class
read
passed
şimdi bakın
syntax
hatası
olmayacaktı
çünkü
my
class
nesneleri
küçüktür
operatörüyle
karşılaştırıldığında
bu fonksiyon
çağırılacaktı
benzer
şekilde
sortun
arkadaşlar
greater
ile
çağırdığım
zaman
yine
syntax
hatası
oldu
çünkü
büyüktür
operatörü
yok
anlaşıldı
değil mi
evet
ama sadece
bu durum
için değil
mesela
şuna
bakınız
izleyin
vektörün
my
class
açılımı
find
algoritmasını
çağırıyorum
bakın
find
weg
begin
end
me
auto
iter
ve burada
da
my
class
me
derliyorum
neden
syntax
hatası
da
hata
mesajını
görmeden
cevabını
verebilmemiz
lazım
e
çünkü
find
algoritmasında
bir
karşılaştırma
işlemi
var
o
karşılaştırmada
eşit eşit
operatörü
yani
equal to
operatörü
kullanıyor
peki
my
class
nesneleri
eşit eşit
karşılaştırmasına
operant olabilir
mi
cevap
hayır
ama
sınıfın
şimdi
şöyle bir
fonksiyonu
olsaydı
bool
operatör
eşit eşit
bu global
bir fonksiyon
da olabilirdi
ya da
c++
20 için
arkadaşlar
spaceship
operatörü
default
edilebilirdi
const
my
class
ref
const
şimdi
bakın
syntax
hatası
olmayacak
çünkü
eşit eşit
karşılaştırması
var
o yüzden
STL
kullanımında
custom
type
söz konusu
olduğunda
bazen
sınıflarınızın
default
constructible
olması gerekiyor
bazen
bazı işlemlerin
yapılması için
sınıfınızın
küçüktür
operatörünü
bir şekilde
sağlaması
gerekiyor
yani
operatör
overloadingden
faydalanması
gerekiyor
bazen
eşit eşit
operatörü
evet
şimdi
tekrar
sort'a geri
dönecek
olursak
birinci
overload için
küçüktür
karşılaştırması
yani
less than
comparable
olması
gerekiyor
eğer
greater'ı
kullanırsanız
greater than
comparable
yani
büyüktür
operatörü
ile
karşılaştırılabiliyor
olması
gerekiyor
peki
tekrar
örneğimize
geri dönelim
arkadaşlar
bakın
sıralama
algoritmasının
stable
olması
şu demek
aynı
değere
sahip
öğeler
sıralamadan
önceki
izafi
görece
konumlarını
koruyacaklar
sıralamadan
önce
hangi
metin
en öndeydi
en baştaydı
yaşındaki
metin
sonra
yaşındaki
metin
sonra
yaşındaki
metin
peki
sıralamadan
sonra
bu sıra
korundu mu
metinler
bir araya
geldi
ama
hayır
o zaman
söz konusu
sıralama
algoritması
sıralamayı
böyle yapıyorsa
bu
stable
sort
değil
ama
şu garantiyi
veriyorsa
efendim
başta
olacak
sonra
yani
sıralamadan
önce
aynı
değerdeki
öğelerin
izafi konumu
korunacak
o zaman
bu
stable
sort
arkadaşlar
tabii
stable
sort
bahsedebilmemiz
için
sıralama
kriterine
eşlik eden
başka
değer
ya da
değerler
olması
gerekiyor
mesela
konteynerda
tutulan
öğeler
intse
sıralamanın
stable
olmasıyla
olmaması
arasında
bizim açımızdan
bir fark
var mı
5 yine
5'in
başka bir
niteliği
yok ki
anlaşıldı
mı
evet
arkadaşlar
peki
burada önemli
soru şu
algoritmanın
stable
olması
sıralama
algoritmasının
stable
olması
bizi
en çok
neden
ilgilendiriyor
bakın
stable'ın
algoritmanın
stable
olmasının
bizi
en çok
ilgilendirdiği
senaryolardan
biri
birden fazla
sıralama
işleminin
yapılması
mesela
izleyin
arkadaşlar
bizim
person
isimli bir
türümüz
olsaydı
class
person
bir person
yaşı
ve
bir de
ismi
ona
ayırt eden
nitelik
olsaydı
suit
string
temleyin
örneği
çok dikkatli
takip edin
ve biz
person
ları
önce
isimlerine
göre sıralasaydık
göre sıraladığımızda
şöyle olduğunu
düşünün
Ali
Ahmet
arkadaşlar
efendim
Can
şöyle gidiyor
Deniz
leksikografical
compare
Enes
Fatih
Fırat
bu şekilde sıraladık
peki
bundan sonra
diyoruz ki
biz bunları
yaşlarına göre
sıralayalım
yani örneğin
buradaki
Ali
27 yaşında
buradaki
Deniz
27 yaşında
buradaki
Fırat
27 yaşında
buradaki
Ahmet
13 yaşında
buradaki
Can
19 yaşında
böyle gidiyor
şimdi ben bunu
yaşlarına göre sıraladığım zaman
arkadaşlar
bildim diyor
ben bunları
yaşlarına göre sıraladığım zaman
Deniz gerçekten
27 yaşındaymış
yaşlarına göre sıraladığım zaman
o zaman
aynı yaştakiler
bir araya gelecek
değil mi?
aynı yaştakilerin bir araya gelmesi demek
bunların bir araya gelmesi demek
peki soru
yaşa göre sıralama yaptığımda
buraya dikkat
yine alfabetik sıranın
bozulmaması için
ilk olarak alfabetik sıralamaya
tabi tutmuştuk ya
yaşa göre sıralama yapan
algoritmanın
kesinlikle
stable sort olması
gerekir
değil mi?
Burayı anladık mı
arkadaşlar?
Kesinlikle
evet
isterseniz bunu
gerçekten bir örnek
üstünde gösterelim
bakın
yani önemsiz gibi görünüyor da
hem üretimde çok önemli
bence
hem de
yine böyle
mülakatlarda çok soruyorlar
çok basit bir sınıf
hemen oluşturalım
person
daha sonra da kullanırız
işte
ne olsun
int
age
stud
string
name
constructor
m age
arkadaşlar
age ile
m name'i
move ederek
name ile
initialize etsin
oldu mu?
oldu
efendim
bir tane
fonksiyon yazalım
friend
sput
ostrim
ref
operatör
left shift
sput
ostrim
ref
os
const
person
ref
e
return
or
parantez içinde
p'nin
arkadaşlar
m age'i
virgül
p'nin
m name'i
ve parantezi kapağı
buraya kadar
derleyelim
en azından
bir person oluşturabiliyoruz
yazdırabiliyoruz
evet
şimdi bakın
vektörün
person açılımı
pvek
fark etmeye çalışın
reserve
bin
random fill
pvek
ya da böyle yazalım doğrudan
random fill
pvek
bin
lambda
return
person
i rent
biraz karışık olacak ama
yaş ne olsun
10 yaşında
70 yaş arası olsun
random
neyim
küme parantezi
noktalı virgül
sanırım oldu
evet şimdi
ben vektöre
bin tane
ne ekledim
arkadaşlar
person ekledim
buraya kadar
derleniyor mu
evet
atasya göstermek için
bunları
bir dosyaya yazayım
upstream
başlık dosyasını
ahledelim
jprint
pvek
newline
ops
alt nokta
tx dosyasına
yazdırıyorum
bir hata varsa
burada çıkacak
parantez içinde
yazacak
evet bakın
bu bizim sıralamadan
önceki halimiz
şimdi
sort algoritmasıyla
sıralıyorum
sort
arkadaşlar
izleyin
svek
pvek
begin
end
karşılaştırma kriteri
olarak
arkadaşlar
yaşı kullanacağım
const
person
p
bir
referans
tam da ifadesi kullanıyorum
const
person
referans
p2
uğraşmamak için
elemanları
public yaptım
çünkü
konu o değil
access control değil
return
p1'in
age'i
m age'i
küçük
p2'nin
m age'i
bakın
şimdi
stable sort ne
çok güzel
görmüş olacağız
ve
dosyaya yazdırıyorum
şimdi yaşa göre
sıralı olacak
değil mi
küçükten büyüye
evet
alt nokta
txt dosyasına
bakalım
bakın
çok güzel bir örnek
olacak
10 yaşındaki
tijen
karo
böyle gidiyor
sonra 11 yaşındakiler
maşallah
böyle gidiyorlar
peki soru
şimdi
bu haldeyken
benim vektörüm
ben bunu
isimlerine göre
sıralasam
sıralıyorum
p1'in
m neymi
küçük
p2'nin
m neymi
şimdi soruyu
anlamaya çalışın
ben
bu haldeyken
şimdi
ikinci
sorutu
çalıştırıyorum
değil mi
bu sıralama
bittikten sonra
şöyle olur mu
arkadaşlar
en başta
diyelim ki
en küçük isim
abdi
12 yaşındaki
17 yaşındaki
abdi
23 yaşındaki
böyle sıralanmış
olur mu
cevap
it depends
neye bağlı
olarak değişir
işte şimdi
kullanacağım
sıralama
algoritmasının
stable
olup olmamasına
göre değişir
peki bakalım
stl'deki
sort
algoritması
stable
mı
çalıştırıyorum
ve
out
txt
bakıyorum
ooo
68 yaşındaki
abdullah
en başta
yaşlara göre
sıralı mı
deniz
hayır
peki bu
algoritma
stable
sort
olsaydı
yaşlara göre
sıralı
olacak mıydı
evet
e çünkü
sıralamadan
önceki
izafi konumlarını
koruması
gerekiyor
sıralamadan
önce
küçük olan
abdullahlar
küçük yaştaki
daha baştaydı
değil mi
ama şimdi
o sıra
bozuldu
peki
başka bir
sıralama
algoritması
stl'deki
ismini
değiştiriyorum
ve
stable
sort
yapıyorum
işte
stable
sort
hangi
garantiyi
veriyor
sıralamadan
önceki
aynı
değere
sahip
öğelerin
izafi konumlarının
korunması
garantisini
veriyor
evet
şimdi
aya bozkır
dediğiniz doğru ama
konumuz
doğrudan o değil
yani ben bir defada
öyle sıralamak
isteseydim
zaten
sıralama kriterini
ona göre
verebilirdim
mesela
peyirin
sıralama kriteri
zaten öyle
anlaşıldı mı
baka şimdi
alt nokta
txt'ye
bu sıralamanın
önceki sıralamanın
etkisini
koruduğunu
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
stable
sortun
ne olduğunu
herkes
anladı mı
evet
o zaman
stable
sort
gerekiyorsa
stable
sortu
gerekmiyorsa
stable
olmayan
normal
sortu
kullanıyorsunuz
eğer
buraya kadar
anlamadığımız
bir şey
yoksa
var mı
sortla
ilgili
ya da
stable
sortla
ilgili
istediğimiz
bir şey
var mı
evet
yine
her ikisi
bir
overload
olarak
l'si
kullanıyor
diğer
overload
ise
arkadaşlar
sizden
binary
predikat
istiyor
devam
edelim
sıralama
algoritmaları
ile
ilgili
ben
kendi
istediğim
sıraya
göre
anlatacağım
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bigo
notasyonunda
stable
daha mı
karmaşık
arkadaşlar
bakın
şöyle bir
güzellik
var
siz
cppreference.com'a
bakarsanız
bütün
algoritmaların
karmaşıklığını
yazıyor
zaten
mesela
sort
algoritması
için
yerini
kaybettim
pardon
şu anda
peki
tekrar bir
önceydi
herhalde
evet
yani herhangi bir
algoritmanın
garanti ettiği
karmaşıklık
seviyesini
görmek için
doğrudan
standarda
bakabilirsiniz
ya da
arkadaşlar
cppreference.com'a
bakabilirsiniz
mesela
sort
bakın
kompleksti
arkadaşlar
evet
o
enlogen
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
stutlesi
kullanıyor
diyor
birincisi
ve
o
enlogen
karmaşıklığında
stable
sort'a
bakalım
yine
enlogen
ama bakın
şimdi
ne diyor
arkadaşlar
işte
burada şöyle bir
koşu koymuş
eğer diyor
ekstra
memori
gerekiyorsa
o
enlog
kare
en
olabilir
demiş
ama
tabii
algoritmanın
karmaşıklığıyla
yapılan
işlem
sayısını
ya da
çalışma zamanı
maliyeti
birebir
aynı şey
değil
değil mi
mesela
daha fazla
işlem yapıyor
olabilir
ama yine
o enlogen
karmaşıklığında
olabilir
yani
kipik olarak
tabii ki
stable
sort'un
maliyeti
normal
sort'a göre
daha yüksek
ama maliyeti
diyorum
ama bu
algoritmanın
ikisinde
iki algoritmanın
karmaşıklığı da
yine o enlogen
olabilir
ya da
best case
worst case
durumları
farklı olabilir
peki
şimdi
arkadaşlar
bazen de
bireyin için
sıralı olup
olmadığını
sınamamız
gerekiyor
işte onun
içinde
kullanacağımız
algoritma
is sorted
son derece
basit bir
algoritma
tabii ki
linear
o en
karmaşıklığında
mesela
yine
vektör üstünde
yazalım
vektör
vekt
mesela bu
küçükten büyüğe
olarak sınırlı durumda
değil mi
is sorted
vague
begin
tabii ki
container'ın
tamamını
üstünde
sorgulamı
yapmak zorunda
değilim
vague
end
boolean döndürüyor
ve
geri dönüş değeri olan
boolean değeri
yazdıralım
arkadaşlar
ve
boolean değerin
şu anda
true olduğunu
göreceğiz
çünkü
küçükten büyüğe
sıralı
ama
örneğin
şöyle
olsaydı
küçükten büyüğe
sıralı
olmayacaktı
şüphesiz
bunun da
yine
binary
predikat alan
bir
overloadu
var
mesela
şöyle
olsaydı
bu seferde
şu anda
false
değer elde
edeceğim
ama
buna da
yine
greater
function
object'ini
gönderseydim
şimdi
büyükten
küçüğe sıralı
olduğu için
true
değer elde
edecektim
anlaşıldı mı
o zaman
bir
engine sıralı
olup olmadığını
bu arada
is sort'ı
tabii ki
random access
iteratör istemiyor
zaten
bakarsanız
iteratör
kategorilerini
ben unutursam
siz bana sorun
ya da
birlikte bakalım
arkadaşlar
forward
iteratör
zaten
linear
karmaşıklıkta
herhangi bir şekilde
random access
iteratör
interface'indeki
bir operasyona
ihtiyacı
yok
değil mi
evet
bir de
çok faydalı
is sort
of
until var
is sort
of
until ise
sıralamanın
arkadaşlar
bittiği yerin
konumunu
döndürüyor
yani nereye
kadar sıralı
türkçeye
çevirseydim
böyle çevirirdim
mesela
bakınız
vektörüm şöyle
olsaydı
sıralama
nerede bozuluyor
eğer algoritmaya
vektörün full range'ini
geçseydim
hop
buraya kadar sıralı
ama burada
bozuldu
işte
is sort
at antil
bravo
Alihan
bana ne döndürecek
sıralamanın
bozulduğu
yani ant konumu
ya da şöyle de
diyebiliriz
bunun geri dönüş
değeri
bizim sıralı
olan kısmın
ant konumu
olacak
hemen
bakalım
auto iter
eşittir
is
sorted
until
weg begin
weg end
ve
arkadaşlar
bu kadar
iter
ve
geri dönüş
değeri
konumuna
bakalım
ip
tabi
ant konumunu
dereferans etmemek
için
biz burada
biliyoruz
sıralımın
7'de
bozulduğunu
iter
eşit
değilse
ya da
doğrudan
distance'ı
yazdırabilirim
see out
o zaman
tamamen sıralı
olması durumunda
bir hata
olmayacak
distance
weg begin
ve
iter
7'in
indeksi
mi oluyor
yakınması
lazım
değil mi
ya da
yıldız iter
5 değerinde
olacaktı
peki
soru
arkadaşlar
üretimde yine
çok sık karşımıza
çıkan bir tema
elimizde
tarihler
var
vektörün
date açılımı
devek
100 bin tane
tarih var
ama biz
tarihlerin ne olduğunu
bilmiyoruz
bunlar
kişilerin
doğum tarihleri
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
ben
en yaşlı
10 kişiyi
10 kişinin
doğum tarihini
bulmak istiyorum
ya da
en genç
10 kişinin
arkadaşlar
ne yapıyorlar
biliyor musunuz
gidiyor
sort
algoritmasını
çağırıyor
küçükten
büyüğe
sıralıyor
ve
işte o sıralı
olan
vektörde
sıralı hale
gelen vektörde
ilk 5 kişiyi
ya da
ilk 10 kişiyi
ilk 10 kişinin
doğum tarihini
kullanıyor
burada
daha fazla
bir maliyet
ödemiş
oluyorsunuz
oysa
partial
sort
algoritması
zaten
bu iş
için var
yani
eğer
size
sizin için
tamamının
sıralanması
gerekmiyorsa
sıralanma
yapılsaydı
ilk
n ö
hangileri
olacaktı
o veriye
o bilgiye
ihtiyacınız varsa
asla
sort
fonksiyonunu
çağırmayın
bunun için
partial
sort
algoritması
var
o zaman
sort
related
algoritmalardan
biri de
bunu gördük
sort
is
sorted
fonksiyonunu
gördük
is
sorted
until
fonksiyonunu
gördük
table
sortu
gördük
arkadaşlar
sortun
bunların
binary
prediket alan
overloblarını
gördük
şimdi sıra
nereye geldi
partial
sort
ama bugünkü
süremiz
burada
sona erdi
artık
bir dahaki
hafta
kaldığımız
yerden
daha iyi
bir sağlık
durumuyla
devam edeceğiz
derse katıldığınız
için
teşekkür ediyorum
bir dahaki
hafta
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar